WE'LL MAKE SENATE COMMITTEE WILL
COME TO ORDER. THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE THIS AFTERNOON. WE
HAVE, 21 ITEMS ON THE AGENDA.
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE HAVE EIGHT
OF THEM ON OUR PROPOSED CONSENT
CALENDAR. ITEM NUMBER FIVE, AB
2340, BONTA, MEDI-CAL EPSD
SERVICES. ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB
2630 BONTA PUPIL HEALTH. ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB 2043, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERNER MEDI-CAL,
NON-MEDICAL AND NON-EMERGENCY
MEDICAL TRANSPORTATION. ITEM
NUMBER 15 AB 2348 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES WITH
AMENDMENTS. ITEM NUMBER 17, AB
2574, VALENCIA. ALCOHOL,
ALCOHOLISM OR DRUG ABUSE
RECOVERY OR TREATMENT PROGRAMS
AND FACILITIES. ITEM NUMBER 18
AB 2680. AGUA CURRY, ALZHEIMER'S
DISEASE, ITEM NUMBER 19, AB 20
701 VIA PADUA MEDICAL MEDI-CAL
DENTAL CLEANINGS AND
EXAMINATIONS WITH AMENDMENTS
CGRTS AND ITEM NUMBER 20, AB
2767, SANTIAGO. FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY STANDARDS BOARD
MEMBERSHIP. WE ALLOW SIX MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY PER SIDE, SO FEEL
FREE TO USE THAT IF YOU MUST. WE
WILL START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
WITH OUR FIRST ITEM, ITEM NUMBER
ONE, AB 1316 TÍNH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN. EMERGENCY
SERVICES, PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY.
MEDICAL CONDITION. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB 1316 TODAY. I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
THANKING THE STAFF FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL. AS THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA IS
PRESENTING IN PSYCHIATRIC IN A
PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS CONTINUES TO
INCREASE, HOSPITAL EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS HAVE BECOME A
CRITICAL PART OF THE SAFETY NET
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO DESPERATELY
NEED PSYCHIATRIC TREATMENT. IN
RECENT YEARS, THOUGH, COUNTIES
HAVE INSTRUCTED HOSPITALS TO
HOLD A PATIENT IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT IF THE PATIENT IS ON
AN INVOLUNTARY PSYCHIATRIC HOLD,
OR IF THE PATIENT HAS MEDI-CAL,
LEADING TO UNNECESSARILY,
PROLONGED STAYS IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT. IN FACT, DATA
SUGGESTS THAT ABOUT 25% OF
INDIVIDUALS BROUGHT TO THE
EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT IN
PSYCHIATRIC CRISIS REMAIN THERE
FOR THREE OR MORE DAYS. THIS HAS
LED TO VALUABLE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT SPACE BEING TAKEN UP
IN HOSPITALS ACROSS THE STATE.
AB 1316 WOULD ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE, CLARIFYING THAT HOSPITALS
MAY ARRANGE A TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATE TRANSFER FOR
PATIENTS REQUIRING INPATIENT
PSYCHIATRIC CARE TO THE FIRST
AVAILABLE BED IN AN INPATIENT
FACILITY, REGARDLESS OF PAYER
PREFERENCE. THIS BILL ALSO
CLARIFIES THAT MEDI-CAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS MUST PAY EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENTS FOR THE CARE THEY
PROVIDE TO MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. THIS WOULD
CODIFY AN EXISTING DCS POLICY
THAT SOUGHT TO ENSURE HOSPITALS
ARE PAID FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES THEY PROVIDE. I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT MY
OFFICE AND THE BILL'S SPONSOR
HAVE HAD POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE OPPOSITION'S ABOUT
THEIR CONCERNS WITH THE BILL,
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THESE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
HOPES OF RESOLVING THESE
CONCERNS WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. AS
CHRISTINE BARLOW, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION, AND RANDALL HAGER,
ON BEHALF OF THE PSYCHIATRIC
PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. GOOD
AFTERNOON, KIRSTEN BARLOW WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION, A SPONSOR OF THE
BILL, THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS AFTERNOON. AND AS MENTIONED
BY OUR AUTHOR, AS MANY AS 1 IN 5
PEOPLE WHO COME TO AN EMERGENCY
ROOM ON ANY GIVEN DAY, ARE THERE
ACTUALLY SEEKING MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS ASSISTANCE. AND WHILE THE
NATIONAL STANDARD OF WHAT ANY OF
US SHOULD EXPECT WHEN WE GO TO
AN EMERGENCY ROOM MIGHT BE THAT
YOU'RE IN, YOU'RE ABLE TO GET
TRIAGED AND TREATED WITHIN ABOUT
FOUR HOURS. AS WAS MENTIONED
BEFORE, IT'S NOT UNCOMMON,
UNFORTUNATELY, FOR FOLKS TO WIND
UP STAYING FOR, MANY HOURS, IF
NOT EVEN DAYS OR WEEKS, WHILE
TREATMENT IS SOUGHT AND A
PLACEMENT AVAILABLE FOR SOMEONE
IN A CRISIS, I THINK WE WANTED
TO REALLY TRY TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A STATEWIDE APPROACH TO HOW
FOLKS ARE BEING HANDLED WHEN
THEY ARE IN AN INPATIENT
EMERGENCY OR IN A PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCY, AND TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE TREATING EMERGENCY
PSYCHIATRIC CONDITIONS THE SAME
WAY ANY ONE OF US WOULD
EXPERIENCE AN EMERGENCY ROOM
VISIT FOR A MEDICAL CONDITION,
WHICH IS THAT YOU WOULD BE
IMMEDIATELY SEEN. AND IF YOU
CAN'T BE STABILIZED OR TREATED
THERE AT THAT HOSPITAL, YOU
WOULD IMMEDIATELY, YOU KNOW,
EFFORTS WOULD BE UNDERTAKEN
IMMEDIATELY TO GET YOU
TRANSFERRED, UNDER FEDERAL LAW,
REALLY, HOSPITALS ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE DOING THIS WITH ANY
PATIENT WHO PRESENTS TO THE
EMERGENCY ROOM AND HEALTH PLANS
OR PAYERS ARE PROHIBITED FROM
REQUIRING THAT PRE-AUTHORIZATION
TO HAPPEN FOR THAT TREATMENT,
INCLUDING FOR ANYONE TO BE
GETTING EMERGENCY PSYCHIATRIC
CARE. SO AB 1316 WOULD ENSURE
PATIENTS AND HOSPITAL ERS ARE NO
LONGER TREATED DIFFERENTLY THAN
ANY OTHER TYPE OF MEDICAL
EMERGENCY THAT PRESENTS IN THE
ER. AND THEN SECONDLY, IT CLEARS
UP A LONG STANDING, SET OF,
UNCLEAR GUIDANCE ABOUT MEDI-CAL
BENEFICIARIES THAT WHEN THEY
COME TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM
SEEKING MENTAL HEALTH CARE, WHO
WHICH SYSTEM ARE WE SUPPOSED TO
HAVE PAY FOR THAT SERVICE? AND
SO IT'S THE INTENT OF OUR BILL
TO CODIFY INTO STATE LAW, A
POLICY OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES THAT OUR
MEDI-CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS, NOT
THE COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM,
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
EMERGENCY ROOM SERVICES. SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CONSIDERING TODAY. AND AS WAS
MENTIONED, WE ARE TALKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION ORGANIZATION THAT
REPRESENTS, A COHORT OF
PSYCHIATRISTS TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND AND ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AS WE CAN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MA'AM. MR. CHAIRMAN
RANDALL HAGER FOR THE
PSYCHIATRIC PHYSICIANS ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIA, IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR PHYSICIAN TO
ENSURE THAT THERE IS NO
DISCRIMINATION IN ANY SYSTEM OF
CARE, PARTICULARLY IN THAT THAT
OF THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS AND
HOSPITALS WHERE THEY TOO OFTEN
LAND. UNFORTUNATELY WE, WE THINK
THAT THIS BILL DOES CLARIFY THAT
COVERAGE FOR A PSYCHIATRIC
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CONDITION,
PARTICULARLY BY HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS, APPLIES REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER THE PATIENT IS VOLUNTARY
OR INVOLUNTARY. THAT'S REALLY
THAT, YOU KNOW, THE LEGAL STATUS
REALLY SHOULD HAVE NOTHING TO DO
WITH WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
TREATED, WHETHER OR NOT AND HOW
THEY'RE TREATED, AND WHETHER OR
NOT THAT THAT TREATMENT IS PAID
FOR. AB 1316 IS PROPOSED TO BE
AMENDED. AND SO IT WILL ALLOW
MEDI-CAL CLARIFY THAT MEDI-CAL
WILL PAY FOR ALL THOSE SERVICES
UP TO THE POINT WHERE THEY'RE
ACTUALLY ADMITTED TO AN
INPATIENT UNIT, THIS IS A LONG
TIME IN COMING, AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL TO SEE THAT, OUR
PSYCHIATRISTS BELIEVE THAT
PATIENTS WITH PSYCHIATRIC
MEDICAL EMERGENCY CONDITIONS
DESERVE TIMELY CARE AND TIMELY
TREATMENT. AND ON THE SAME TERMS
AND CONDITIONS AS PATIENTS WITH
OTHER NON PSYCHIATRIC MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. SO THAT WOULD
INCLUDE TIMELY TRANSPORTATION.
BUT I THINK WE'RE IN A BAD
POSITION IF WE'RE ALLOWING
HEALTH CARE PLANS AND INSURERS
TO PICK AND CHOOSE PATIENT
COVERAGE LEVELS, REIMBURSEMENT
LEVELS OR TRANSFER OPTIONS BASED
ON WHETHER OR NOT THERE'S A
LEGAL STATUS FOR THAT PARTICULAR
PATIENT, IT JUST SHOULD BE
STRAIGHT ACROSS THE BOARD, THE
SAME. SO IT LEVELS THE PLAYING
FIELD. THIS THIS BILL DOES WITH
RESPECT TO THOSE LEGAL STATUSES
AND HELPS CLARIFY THAT BOTH
QUALITY, AND STANDARD OF CARE IS
THE SAME FOR BOTH, AND THAT
HOSPITALS GET REIMBURSED FOR IT
EITHER WAY, WHICH IS IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE? THANK YOU. CHAIR THANK
YOU. CHAIR, TIM MADDEN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE, GRACE COPELAND, ON
BEHALF OF PROVIDENCE, IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU. MA'AM. NEXT, PLEASE
, THERESA COMSTOCK WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
HEARING ROOM? ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO THE
TABLE IN THE WELL. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. DYLAN ELLIOTT WITH
CHAU AND L®NG HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF PSYCHIATRISTS, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO AB 1316, AS IS
CURRENTLY IN PRINT, WOULD LIKE
TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AUTHORS, OFFICE
STAFF AND THE SPONSORS FOR THE
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE BEEN HAVING, WHERE SHOULD
THE BILL MOVE TODAY? LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THOSE
CCP'S CONCERNS CAN BE BOILED
DOWN TO, DESPITE BEST
INTENTIONS, A PORTION OF THE
BILL THAT COULD BE INTERPRETED
AS RELIEVING HOSPITALS OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROVIDE
ASSESSMENTS FOR 5150 INDIVIDUALS
WHO PRESENT VOLUNTARILY
SOMETHING THAT WE FEAR COULD BE
A DISASTER TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND THE STATE, AGAIN, WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC THAT ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS CAN LEAD US TO A
PLACE THAT CCEP CAN CONSIDER
REMOVING ITS OPPOSITION. WANT TO
REITERATE OUR THANKS FOR THE
DIALOG AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE CONVERSATIONS,
BUT MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
TODAY YOU SEND. HAVE YOU
SUBMITTED LANGUAGE? I BELIEVE
SO, YES. AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
WE'RE HAVING SOME BACK AND
FORTH. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE? SEEING SEEING NONE, SO
REMEMBER, I GUESS YOU MAY CLOSE.
ALL RIGHT. WELL, WHEN THE TIME
IS RIGHT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AS SOON AS WE SECURE A
QUORUM, WE'LL REQUEST A MOTION
AND TAKE A VOTE. THANK YOU ALL
FOR APPEARING TODAY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NEXT ITEM. LET'S SEE
WHO WE HAVE. WE DO. WE HAVE, AB
1926 MEMBER CONNOLLY, PLEASE
STEP FORWARD. PROCEED WHEN READY
. THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
GOOD AFTERNOON. I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF FOR THEIR WORK AND
INPUT ON THIS BILL. AB 1926
WOULD REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS
RENEWED ON OR AFTER JULY 1ST,
2025, TO COVER DIETARY ENTERAL
FORMULAS FOR THE TREATMENT OF
REGIONAL ENTERITIS. THESE
FORMULAS CAN BE A SUCCESSFUL
ALTERNATIVE TO MEDICATION
TREATMENT FOR SEVERAL DIGESTIVE
DISEASES, INCLUDING REGIONAL
ENTERITIS, WHICH WE KNOW
COMMONLY AS CROHN'S DISEASE.
THIS THERAPY HAS SUBSTANTIAL
BENEFITS FOR ALL CROHN'S
PATIENTS, BUT MOST NOTABLY
PEDIATRIC PATIENT, BECAUSE THEY
MAY NOT HAVE ACCESS TO OR MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO USE CERTAIN
MEDICATIONS AS. ADDITIONALLY,
PATIENTS WITH CROHN'S DISEASE
CAN UTILIZE MEDICALLY NECESSARY
FORMULAS FOR NUTRITIONAL SUPPORT
AND TO HELP THEM ACHIEVE
REMISSION EARLY TREATMENT
OPTIONS FOR DIGESTIVE DISEASES
LIKE CROHN'S HAVE PROVEN TO
REDUCE HARM AND INCREASE QUALITY
OF LIFE. THERE IS NO REASON WHY
CALIFORNIANS SUFFERING FROM
CHRONIC ILLNESSES CANNOT LEAD
FULL AND PRODUCTIVE LIVES. AB
1926 PROVIDES PATIENTS WITH A
PROVEN, SUCCESSFUL ALTERNATIVE
TO CERTAIN MEDICATIONS, WHICH
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS MAY
RECOMMEND WHEN COMPLICATIONS
SUCH AS WEIGHT LOSS SURGERY,
OBSTRUCTION, OR SEVERE
INFLAMMATION PREVENT PATIENTS
FROM GETTING THE RIGHT
NUTRIENTS. ENTERAL NUTRITION, OR
N AS IT'S KNOWN, IS A WAY TO
GIVE THE PATIENT'S BODY WHAT IT
NEEDS TO STAY HEALTHY. IAN IS
USUALLY TAKEN IN THE FORM OF
NUTRIENT RICH FORMULA, INCLUDING
BOOST, ENSURE AND OR GAIN.
DIGESTIVE DISEASES LIKE CROHN'S
DISEASE AFFECT MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS, WITH AS MANY AS
70,000 NEW CASES OF IBD
DIAGNOSED EACH YEAR. I'LL ALSO
ADD AB 1926 IS ACTUALLY A REDO
OF MY BILL FROM LAST YEAR, AB
620, WHICH PASSED THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE WITH NEAR UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND ACTUALLY
MADE ITS WAY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK. AB 620 WAS VETOED BECAUSE
UNDER THE EXCLUSIONS SECTION OF
ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS
BENCHMARK PLAN, OUTPATIENT ORAL
NUTRITION SUCH AS DIETARY
SUPPLEMENTS, HERBAL SUPPLEMENTS,
WEIGHT LOSS AIDS, FORMULAS, AND
FOOD ARE LISTED. HOW NEVER.
THERE ARE EXCEPTIONS TO THIS
EXCLUSION, AND AFTER
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE, THE LANGUAGE FOR AB 1926
WAS AMENDED TO MORE CLOSELY
ALIGN WITH THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BENCHMARK PLAN AND TO HELP
ADDRESS THE VETO MESSAGE, I WILL
NOW PASS IT OFF TO MY WITNESS,
RYAN SPENCER, REP RESENTING THE
CROHN'S AND COLITIS FOUNDATION,
THE BILL SPONSOR, SIR. PLEASE
PROCEED SIR. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. RYAN SPENCER, ON BEHALF
OF THE CROHN'S AND COLITIS
FOUNDATION, I THINK THE AUTHORS
HE ENCAPSULATED REALLY ALL THE
NEED AND THE INTENT OF AB 1926.
BUT I JUST WANT TO REITERATE TWO
IMPORTANT POINTS. ONE IS
SOMETHING HE JUST CONCLUDED
WITH, IS THIS BILL DID PASS OUT
OF THIS COMMITTEE, A VERSION OF
THIS BILL, AB 620, PASSED AS
COMMITTEE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. IT WAS A MUCH MORE
EXPANSIVE BILL APPLIED TO ALL
DIGESTIVE DISEASES AND INHERITED
METABOLIC DISORDERS. THIS ONE,
AS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED, IS MORE
NARROWLY TAILORED AND TARGETED
TOWARD REGIONAL ENTERITIS AND
SPECIFICALLY STATES, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NUTRITIONAL DRINKS
AND THE REASON WHY THAT LANGUAGE
IS SO NARROW IS BECAUSE WE WANT
TO MORE CLOSELY ALIGN WITH THE
BENCHMARK PLAN, AS CLOSE AS WE
COULD POSSIBLY DO. THE SECOND
POINT I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT HAS
TO DO WITH COST, WHICH ALWAYS
COMES UP WITH HEALTH CARE
MANDATE BILLS. THE REPORT THAT
WAS CITED AND WILL BE CITED BY
THE OPPOSITION WHEN THEY COME
UP, WAS NOT ACTUALLY CREATED FOR
1926. IT WAS FROM THE PREVIOUS
VERSION, AB 620, WHICH, LIKE I
SAID, WAS A MORE EXPANSIVE BILL.
SO THE COST FOR ONE IS PROBABLY
LARGER THAN IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
IF A NEW REPORT CAME OUT,
SPECIFICALLY, SPECIFICALLY
TAILORED TO 1926, THEY CITED A
COST OF $24 MILLION TO THE
OVERALL HEALTH COST OF THE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. I THINK IT'S
FAIR TO ASSUME THERE WILL BE A
COST. IT IS A MANDATE. BUT WHAT
IT FAILS TO ACKNOWLEDGE AS THIS
IS A MUCH CHEAPER AND LESS
EXPENSIVE ALTERNATIVE THAN WHAT
IS CURRENTLY AVAILABLE NOW AND
WHICH IS TYPICALLY COVERED,
WHICH ARE BIOLOGICS. SO THE
OPTION THAT IS GIVEN TO PATIENTS
IS THIS IS YOU CAN EITHER GET
PARTICULARLY PEDIATRIC PATIENTS.
AS THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER SAID, YOU
CAN PUT YOUR DISEASE IN
REMISSION BY USING NUTRITIONAL
FORMULAS, WHICH YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO PAY OUT OF POCKET. IT'S
A FEW HUNDRED BUCKS FOR A CASE
OF THESE THINGS. OR IT COULD BE,
OR YOU CAN PAY A CO-PAY OF 15 TO
$20, WHATEVER IT MAY BE FOR A
BIOLOGIC, WHICH IN REALITY COULD
BE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS, BECAUSE
THAT'S TYPICALLY WHAT'S COVERED.
SO THE PATIENT IS PROBABLY GOING
TO OPT FOR THE COPAY BECAUSE
IT'S CHEAPER FOR THEM OUT OF
POCKET. BUT FOR THE OVERALL
HEALTH COST OF HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM, IT IS A MUCH LESS
EXPENSIVE ALTERNATIVE TO WHAT IS
WHAT IS OFFERED NOW. AND IT IS
EQUALLY AS PROVEN, EQUALLY
EFFECTIVE AS HE MENTIONED. SO
WITH THAT, I'D LIKE TO ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURE
ONLY? PLEASE THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. DAVID GONZALEZ,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR.
I WOULD KIDANI REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SIR. YES, MA'AM. THANK YOU.
AARON TAYLOR WITH POLITICAL
SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. NEXT, PLEASE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ORTHODONTISTS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. ALEX KHN, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORT. THANKS
FOR JOINING US. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION?
LET'S SEE. SEEING GOING GOING
GONE OKAY. SEEING NONE. SO
REMEMBER YOU'RE LUCKY. LET ME
BRING IT BACK TO MY COLLEAGUES.
ANY QUESTIONS? COMMENTS,
CONCERNS COLLEAGUE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AND CONCERNS OKAY. IT'S
YOUR LUCKY DAY, SIR. THANK YOU.
CHAIR, I WILL TAKE THAT, AND AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. AS SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND
TAKE A VOTE. THANKS FOR BEING
HERE. THANK YOU. NICE
PRESENTATION. ITEM NUMBER THREE,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON, AB,
1970. MENTAL HEALTH, BLACK
MENTAL HEALTH NAVIGATOR
CERTIFICATION. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY, SIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MR. CHAIR, SENATOR
MENGIBAR, THE 202 FAITHFUL'S OF
THE COMMITTEE, WANT TO THANK THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB 1970,
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION TO CREATE A
BLACK MENTAL HEALTH NAVIGATOR
CERTIFICATION WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM, THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT, TO
DEVELOP SPECIFIC TRAINING AND
MENTAL HEALTH RESOURCES,
INCLUDING CRISIS INTERVENTION,
TRAINING AND NON-EMERGENCY
CASES. ENTRY LEVEL ASSESSMENT,
NAVIGATOR SUPPORT, AND
CULTURALLY SPECIFIC PRACTICES
RELATIVE TO HELPING TO CONNECT
INDIVIDUALS WITH LICENSED MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS AND
WELLNESS SERVICES. IT WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE TO COLLECT ANNUAL DATA
AS WELL, AND TO PUBLISH THAT
DATA, FROM INDIVIDUALS THAT EARN
A CERTIFICATE, AS WELL AS THE
NUMBER OF WHO ARE ACTIVELY
EMPLOYED AS COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS, WITH ME TODAY, I HAVE
DOMINIC PAXTON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BLACK WOMEN'S HEALTH
PROJECT, TO SPEAK ON ON THE
IMPACT OF THIS BILL. AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. PLEASE
PROCEED. WE HAVE SOME TRUTHS TO
BE SELF-EVIDENT. LET ME JUST
HAVE YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELF. FOR
THE RECORD, MY NAME IS DOMINIC
PAXTON. I'M THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM MANAGER OF
CALIFORNIA BLACK WOMEN'S HEALTH
PROJECT. THANK YOU. PLEASE
PROCEED. WE HOLD SOME TRUTHS TO
BE SELF-EVIDENT. AND THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS AND THE NEED FOR
HELP IN BLACK COMMUNITIES IS
AMONG THOSE TRUTHS. IT'S AN
HONOR TO STAND HERE TODAY ON THE
BEHALF OF SONIA YOUNG ADAM, CEO
OF CALIFORNIA BLACK WOMEN'S
HEALTH PROJECT, WHO WAS UNABLE
TO BE WITH BE WITH US TODAY
DEDICATED, INTENTIONAL AND
CERTIFIED BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
NAVIGATION IS NECESSARY TO
SUPPORT PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION CARE FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH BARRIERS AND GAPS FACED
BY BLACK CALIFORNIANS. WE
APPLAUD ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON
FOR HIS BOLDNESS IN BRINGING
FORTH AB 1970. THE PROPOSED
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM WOULD
BRING TWO IMPORTANT CHANGES TO
ADDRESS OUR COMMUNITIES MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. NUMBER ONE,
CERTIFICATION EQUATES TO
PROFESSIONALISM, AND KNOWLEDGE
AND EXPERIENCE. FOR THOSE OF US
ALREADY ENGAGED AND COMMITTED TO
NAVIGATION. AND NUMBER TWO,
CERTIFICATION FOR OUR COMMUNITY
IN PARTICULAR, IS A TESTAMENT TO
THE RECOGNITION THAT CULTURE,
HERITAGE, HISTORY AND RACE ARE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
AND WELLNESS. CALIFORNIA BLACK
WOMEN'S HEALTH PROJECT IS
COMMITTED TO BETTER MENTAL
HEALTH FOR BLACK WOMEN, GIRLS,
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES. WE
SUPPORT AB 1970 AND WE ARE
COMMITTED TO USING OUR DECADES
OF EXPERIENCE IN TRAINING HEALTH
NAVIGATORS, ADVOCATES AND
ACTIVISTS TO PROVIDE
CONSULTATION AND ADVICE TO ANY
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE AGENCIES
WORKING TO IMPROVE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE FOR BLACK
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON, THANK
YOU TO THIS COMMITTEE, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO STAND HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE.
THANK YOU MA'AM. GOOD AFTERNOON.
SYMPHONY BABI, ON BEHALF OF
PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. NEXT, PLEASE.
VANESSA CADENA WITH CP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, CAP S WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD AND
FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM, BRANDON MAKI
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. GOOD TO
SEE YOU, SIR. NEXT. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? OKAY.
LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. FIRST, THE LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF
THERE ARE ANY, AND THEN OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SEEING
NONE. LET'S BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO MY COLLEAGUE. ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS, CONCERNS,
SEEING NONE. SOME REMEMBER YOUR
LUCKY DAY. YOU MAY CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM AND
TAKE A MOTION, WE'LL TAKE A
VOTE. THANK YOU BOTH FOR BEING
HERE. NEXT ITEM. I THINK I
THOUGHT I SEE WE HAVE OUR
ASSEMBLY HEALTH CHAIR, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA, WHO HAS SEVERAL
ITEMS WE WILL START IF SHE
PLEASES, WITH ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1975 MEDI-CAL.
MEDICALLY SUPPORTED FOOD AND
NUTRITION INTERVENTIONS CHAIR.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, CHAIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
SOON TO BE MEMBERS, FOOD IS
LIFE. FOOD IS SUSTENANCE. FOOD
IS MEDICINE. FOOD IS MEDICINE IS
A PRIORITY BILL TO ME AND IS A
LEGISLATIVE REPARATIONS PRIORITY
BILL IS PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. UPON
APPROPRIATION OF FUNDS, AB 1975
WOULD MAKE MEDICALLY SUPPORTIVE
FOOD AND NUTRITION INTERVENTIONS
A COVERED BENEFIT TO ALL
MEDI-CAL RECIPIENTS WHEN DEEMED
MEDICALLY NECESSARY BY THEIR
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS. AS AB
1975 WOULD DIRECT, THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO FORM A COMMITTEE TO
ISSUE GUIDANCE FOR IMPLEMENTING
THESE INTERVENTION SERVICES. OUR
WITNESSES TODAY GIVING TESTIMONY
INCLUDE A DOCTOR, STEPHEN CHEN,
CHIEF MEDICAL OFFICER OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY RECIPE FOR HEALTH
PROGRAM, AND ELIZABETH DURAN, A
PATIENT PARTICIPANT IN RECIPE
FOR HEALTH. THEIR STORIES WILL
BE VERY IMPACTFUL. IN ADDITION,
WE HAVE AARON FRANEY FROM THE
FOOD IS MEDICINE COLLABORATIVE
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
LET ME JUST ASK YOU TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD BEFORE
SPEAKING. I'LL LET YOU FLIP A
COIN TO SEE WHO GOES FIRST. HI,
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH DURAN.
THANK YOU. MA'AM, DO YOU WANT TO
PROCEED FIRST? SURE MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH DURAN. I LIVE IN THE
EAST BAY, AND I'M HERE TO SHARE
ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE WITH OPEN
SOURCE WELLNESS AND RECIPE FOR
HEALTH. THE PANDEMIC CAUSED ME
TO LOSE MY JOB OF 30 YEARS,
INCLUDING MY HEALTH INSURANCE. A
KNEE INJURY LED TO SURGERY, I
GAINED WEIGHT, I TOOK MEDICATION
FOR HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE. MY
DOCTOR OF TEN YEARS PRESCRIBED
PILLS FOR ANXIETY. SOON AFTER, I
FOUND MYSELF ON MEDI-CAL, ADDED
TO BURSCOUGH VASQUEZ HEALTH
CENTER. I WAS TERRIFIED. MY NEW
DOCTOR SUGGESTED A PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD INCLUDE FREE ORGANIC
VEGETABLES ONCE A WEEK, PLUS
HEALTH AND WELLNESS COACHING
CALLED RECIPE FOR HEALTH. HE
DESCRIBED THAT I WOULD LEARN
ABOUT NUTRITION AND BE SUPPORTED
BY A FRIENDLY COMMUNITY. WITHIN
A FEW DAYS, I GOT A PHONE CALL
FROM THE RECIPE FOR HEALTH TEAM
TO ENROLL ME IN THE PROGRAM.
WHAT I INITIALLY ENVISIONED AS A
WEIGHT LOSS PROGRAM TURNED OUT
TO BE MUCH MORE THAN I EVER
IMAGINED. NOT ONLY DID I RECEIVE
BEAUTIFUL, ORGANIC GREENS AND
VEGETABLES, I LEARNED OF THEIR
NUTRITIONAL VALUE AND HOW TO
INCORPORATE THEM INTO A HEALTHY
DIET IN THE MOST AFFORDABLE WAY.
I AM COOKING AND EATING MUCH
BETTER TODAY. I LOOK FOR NEW
RECIPES ONLINE THAT INCLUDE
COLLARD GREENS AND SWISS CHARD,
THINGS THAT USED TO BE
UNFAMILIAR. I LEARNED HOW TO
INCORPORATE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY INTO MY DAILY
LIFE. IN ALL MY YEARS WITH
PRIVATE HEALTH INSURANCE, NO ONE
EVER ASKED ME IF I WANTED TO
LEARN ABOUT HEALTHY EATING OR
OFFERED RESOURCES. OPEN SOURCE
WELLNESS HAS MADE ME FEEL WANTED
AND CARED FOR AGAIN. WHEN I WAS
TURNED AWAY ELSEWHERE, MY WORRY
HAS BECOME LESS, MY SLEEP, MORE
MY BLOOD PRESSURE IS AT A
HEALTHY LEVEL. I'M FEELING HAPPY
AGAIN AND NOT FROM A PILL. I
BECAME SO INSPIRED THAT I STAND
AS A PEER LEADER, WANTING TO
INSPIRE OTHERS WHO MAY BE IN A
DIM PLACE, AS I ONCE WAS IN
CALIFORNIA, ACROSS THE STATE,
CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE STATE
LIKE ME, NEED THESE CRITICAL
PROGRAMS TO SUPPORT OUR HEALTH.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR AB 1975, WHICH WILL
ENSURE PROGRAMS LIKE RECIPE FOR
HEALTH BECOMING PERMANENT
MEDI-CAL BENEFITS. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE. IT HAS BEEN AN HONOR
. LÀ. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TODAY. WE EAT A LOT OF COLLARD
GREENS IN THE SOUTH. YES,
DOCTOR. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR STEPHEN CHEN,
AND I AM A FAMILY PHYSICIAN WITH
24 YEARS OF CLINICAL AND
ADMINISTRATIVE EXPERIENCE IN THE
SAFETY NET HEALTH SYSTEMS. I
SERVE AS THE CHIEF MEDICAL
OFFICER FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY'S
FOOD AS MEDICINE PROGRAM, AND I
REGULARLY TESTIFY TO
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS AND
FEDERAL AGENCIES ABOUT FOOD AS
MEDICINE. I'LL PLACE MR. CHAN'S
STORY IN CONTEXT TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION, WHY SUPPORT FOOD AS
MEDICINE PROGRAMS THROUGH THIS
BILL? FIRST, THAT AMERICANS ARE
SICK. 6 IN 10 ADULTS HAVE
CHRONIC CONDITIONS LIKE DIABETES
OR HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE, AND THE
TWO MAJOR DRIVERS OF THESE
CHRONIC CONDITIONS ARE AN
UNHEALTHY DIET, WHICH IS NOW THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH,
RESULTING IN 500,000 AMERICANS
FATALLY REYES PER YEAR AND FOOD
INSECURITY, WHICH CAN DOUBLE
ONE'S RISK OF DEVELOPING A
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITION. OAN
FOOD IS MEDICINE. PROGRAMS LIKE
RECIPE FOR HEALTH WILL ADDRESS
CAUSES OF ROOT OF CHRONIC HEALTH
CONDITIONS, THE ROOT CAUSES OF
CHRONIC HEALTH CONDITIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. IN ALAMEDA ALONE, WE
HAVE SCALED ACROSS TEN SITES,
TEN CLINICAL SITES AND SERVED
OVER 6000 PATIENTS, 83% OF WHOM
ARE BIPOC. IMAGINE MISS DURANT'S
STORY MULTIPLIED THOUSANDS OF
TIMES IN YOUR DISTRICT. CITIZENS
LIKE MR. RAND WILL WALK INTO
YOUR LOCAL FOOD AS MEDICINE
HEALTH CENTERS, WHERE A MEDICAL
ASSISTANT SCREENS THEM FOR FOOD
INSECURITY. A CLINICIAN THEN
PRESCRIBES TWO THINGS. NUMBER
ONE, PRODUCE DELIVERED TO YOUR
DOORSTEP. PAIRED WITH NUMBER
TWO, HEALTH COACHING TO SUSTAIN
ALL OF THESE LIFE HABIT CHANGES.
SO IT'S THE FOOD AND THE
SUSTENANCE BECAUSE THE PRODUCE
IS GROWN LOCALLY BY BIPOC
FARMERS, EVERY $1 THAT IS SPENT
ON PRESCRIBED PRODUCE GENERATES
$1.90 FOR THE LOCAL ECONOMY. THE
PRODUCE IS GROWN USING
REGENERATIVE AND ORGANIC FARMING
APPROACHES, WHICH MINIMIZE TOXIC
PESTICIDE RESIDUES AND INCREASE
THE FOOD'S NUTRIENT DENSITY. TO
IMPROVE HEALTH. IN FACT, OUR
EVALUATION TEAM FROM STANFORD
AND UC SAN FRANCISCO REPORTED
THE FOLLOWING HIGHLIGHTS AND
JUST A FEW HIGHLIGHTS. NUMBER
ONE, A THIRD OF OUR PATIENTS
WITH PREDIABETES OR DIABETES
SHOWED A CLINICALLY SIGNIFICANT
REDUCTION IN THEIR BLOOD SUGARS.
NUMBER TWO, TWO THIRDS OF OUR
PATIENTS IMPROVE THEIR
CHOLESTEROL INDICATORS, REDUCING
HEART DISEASE RISK. NUMBER THREE
EMERGENCY ROOM VISITS DECREASED
BY 15. SO IN CLOSING, I URGE YOU
TO MAKE HISTORY BY VOTING AYE ON
1975 TO MAKE FOOD AS MEDICINE A
PERMANENT COVERED BENEFIT IN
MEDI-CAL AND TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND
THE ECONOMIC VITALITY IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU ALL SO
MUCH. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE, PLEASE, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. DERBY KERNAN, ON
BEHALF OF SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS,
MEALS ON WHEELS PROJECT OPEN
HAND, THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF FOOD BANKS AND LEADINGAGE,
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANKS
FOR JOINING US. YES, MA'AM. HI.
CHRISTY FOY WITH ARNOLD AND
ASSOCIATES HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA KIDNEY CARE ALLIANCE
AND FRESENIUS MEDICAL CARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. RYAN SPENCER, ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OB-GYN DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU. YES, MA'AM. KELLY
BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA, THE
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. VANESSA KHN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND SUPPORT
. THANK YOU. YES, MA'AM.
CHRISTINE SMITH, HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA, AND SUPPORT, THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. TAYLOR
ROCHON, ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
FRESH FRUIT ASSOCIATION AND
AMERICAN PISTACHIO GROWERS IN
SUPPORT. THANKS, SYMPHONY BARBI,
ON BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WHITNEY
FRANCIS WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, BRANDON MAKI
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANKS
DYLAN ELLIOTT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. RAND
MARTIN, ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION, IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MOORLACH, ON BEHALF OF THE
GREATER SACRAMENTO URBAN LEAGUE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. JOE LEÓN
NADERA WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALEX KAHN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANKS
MARVIN PINEDA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SIR. NEXT, PLEASE, ROBERT
BOYKIN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
PLANS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
JARED MOSS, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH SUPPORT,
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. ANDY
NAIDOO-HARRIS WITH THE
AGRICULTURAL INSTITUTE OF MARIN
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, DAVID
GONZALEZ, ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN DIABETES ASSOCIATION,
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? NOW
LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. MADAM
CHAIR, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU.
THIS BILL IS, BEEN, BECOME A
HEART PROJECT FOR ME OVER THE
COURSE OF THE LAST TWO YEARS.
AND MY STAFF AND VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THE IDEA OF ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA ACTUALLY GETS TO SAVE
MONEY BY INVESTING IN HEALTH
CARE AND PREVENTATIVELY, THE
REALITY IS THAT CALIFORNIA
STANDS TO BE ABLE TO SAVE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS, IF NOT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, IF WE WOULD
JUST DO A VERY SIMPLE THING,
WHICH IS ALLOW PEOPLE TO BE ABLE
TO USE MEDICALLY SUPPORTIVE
PLANS, TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THEIR HEALTH CONDITIONS. WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR I VOTE AS SOON AS WE GET A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND
DO THAT. VOTE YOUR NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN, AB 2786
CERTIFIED MOBILE FARMERS
MARKETS. PROCEED WHEN READY.
CONTINUING WITH THE THEME, THANK
YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I WANT
TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AB 2786
ESTABLISHES A PATHWAY FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO UTILIZE THEIR
WILK BENEFITS AT MOBILE FARMERS
MARKETS, WHICH SUPPORTS THE
CONSUMPTION OF FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES THROUGH THE WICK
FARMERS MARKET NUTRITION
PROGRAM, ALSO KNOWN AS THE WICK
FM FMNP MOBILE FARMERS MARKETS
BRING FARM FRESH FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES DIRECTLY TO
COMMUNITIES TO OTHER THAT
OTHERWISE LACK ACCESS. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT CURRENTLY,
MOBILE FARMERS MARKETS ARE NOT
AUTHORIZED TO REDEEM WICK
BENEFITS. TO ADDRESS THIS BILL,
AB 2786 DOES TWO THINGS. FIRST,
IT CREATES A DEFINITION OF A
CERTIFIED MOBILE FARMER'S MARKET
AND HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE. AND
SECOND, IT DIRECTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
INCLUDE CERTIFIED MOBILE FARMERS
MARKETS IN THE STATE PLAN, WHICH
THEY SUBMIT ANNUALLY TO
PARTICIPATE IN WICK FMT, FMNP
FMNP. THE STATE PLAN IS APPROVED
BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE DPH TO
AUTHORIZE CERTIFIED FARMERS
MARKETS TO PARTICIPATE IN WICK
FMNP BY ALLOWING PARTICIPANTS TO
USE THEIR BENEFITS AT MFM'S.
THIS BILL WILL INCREASE ACCESS
TO NUTRITIOUS FOOD FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT, I HAVE SUSIE
SUTPHIN, COMMUNITY FOOD PROGRAM
MANAGER, CENTER FOR LAND BASED
LEARNING, AND ANDY NADJARI'S,
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
AGRICULTURAL INSTITUTE OF MARIN.
OKAY. THANK YOU. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELVES FOR THE RECORD BEFORE
YOU SPEAK AND PROCEED WHEN
READY. MA'AM OKAY. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR ROTH AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
SUSIE SUTPHIN. I AM THE
COMMUNITY FOOD PROGRAM MANAGER
WITH THE CENTER FOR LAND BASED
LEARNING. FOR MORE THAN 30
YEARS, THE CENTER FOR LAND BASED
LEARNING HAS HELPED ASPIRING
FARMERS AND ENVIRONMENTAL
STEWARDS PURSUE CAREERS AND
RESOURCES AND POSSIBILITIES
WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S RICH WORKING
LANDS. IN 2021, WE LAUNCHED A
MOBILE FARMERS MARKET AS PART OF
OUR COMMUNITY FOOD PROGRAM. ITS
GOAL IS TO ENSURE EQUAL ACCESS
TO LOCAL, SEASONAL, SUSTAINABLY
GROWN PRODUCE AND PROVIDE
INNOVATIVE NEW MARKET
OPPORTUNITIES FOR SMALL, SMALL,
SMALL, SMALL FAMILY FARMS. IT
SERVES PRIMARILY ETHNICALLY
DIVERSE LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
THROUGHOUT YOLO COUNTY THAT
IDENTIFY AS FOOD INSECURE BY THE
USDA. WE'RE ADDRESSING FOOD
ACCESS CHALLENGES BY NOT ONLY
MAKING IT AFFORDABLE, BUT
CONVENIENT BY GOING TO THE
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT NEED US MOST
AND HAVE THE LEAST ACCESS TO
FRESH, HEALTHY FOOD TO BETTER
SERVE OUR LOW INCOME CUSTOMERS.
WE ACCEPT CALFRESH BENEFITS AND
PROVIDE MARKET MATCH SO THAT
ANYONE WHO QUALIFIES CAN GET $20
IN PRODUCE FOR JUST $10. WE ALSO
WE DON'T ACCEPT WICK, OF COURSE,
YET, BUT WE HAVE PRIVATELY
FUNDRAISED TO OFFER A 50% OFF
DISCOUNT TO MEMBERS WHO HAVE
WICK, WE SUPPORT AB 27 2786 TO
RECOGNIZE THE SIGNIFICANT ROLE
THAT MOBILE FARMERS MARKETS PLAY
IN IMPROVING NUTRITION AND
HEALTH FOR WOMEN AND FAMILIES
WHO ARE LOW INCOME, MOBILE
FARMER'S MARKETS MISSION ARE TO
SUPPORT LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES,
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
WE ARE NOT WHOLESALERS IN THE
SAME WAY THAT BOOKMOBILES HAVE
EXTENDED THE REACH OF PUBLIC
LIBRARIES, MOBILE FARMER'S
MARKETS EXTEND THE REACH AND
IMPACT OF CERTIFIED FARMERS
MARKETS BY CONNECTING MORE
COMMUNITIES WITH CALIFORNIA'S
SMALL TO MID-SIZE FARMERS. THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE A PATHWAY FOR
MOBILE FARMERS MARKETS TO ACCEPT
WICK FARMERS MARKET NUTRITION
BENEFITS AND IN TURN, ALLOW MORE
CALIFORNIANS WITH ACCESS TO
HEALTHY, FRESH FOOD GROWN
LOCALLY. TEN OTHER US STATES
ALLOW MOBILE FARMERS MARKETS TO
ACCEPT WICK. IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO BE THE 11TH.
ADEQUATE NUTRITION IS A KEY TO
PREVENTING CHRONIC CONDITIONS
AND REDUCING HEALTH CARE COSTS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF THIS BILL,
CALIFORNIA CAN LEAD THE WAY IN
PROVIDING NEW AND INNOVATIVE
ACCESS POINTS TO CONNECT FARMERS
WITH WICK PARTICIPANTS. THANK
YOU TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON AB 2786. THANK YOU, THANK YOU
MA'AM. SIR SURE, ANDY NADJARI'S
WITH THE AGRICULTURAL INSTITUTE
OF MARIN. I'LL KEEP IT BRIEF, WE
ARE TRYING TO CLOSE A LOOPHOLE
WITHIN CALIFORNIA WHERE MOTHERS
WHO ARE SHOPPING WITH THEIR WICK
FARMERS MARKET NUTRITION
BENEFITS ARE NOT ABLE TO USE
THOSE AT MOBILE FARMERS MARKETS.
AND WE THINK THAT A REGULATORY
CHANGE, WOULD HELP TO ENSURE
THAT ALL MOTHERS WHO ARE USING
WICK CAN SHOP AT MOBILE FARMERS
MARKETS TO GET ACCESS TO THE
BEST PRODUCE THAT'S GROWN RIGHT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SO WE THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA FOR HER
LEADERSHIP AND REQUEST FULLY,
RESPECT AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. THANKS FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? SEEING NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE. MADAM CHAIR, YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU. CHAIR. WHEN I
WAS GROWING UP IN NEW YORK CITY,
ON EVERY SUNDAY, MY MOTHER AND I
WOULD HAVE TO TAKE A BUS TO GO
TO THE FOOD MARKET TO BE ABLE TO
GET HER FAVORITE, FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES THAT THEN BECAME
MINE, THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO NOT TREAT POVERTY AS
SOMETHING THAT IS SUSPICIOUS,
BUT ESSENTIALLY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF BY ALLOWING ALL OF
OUR PEOPLE WHO ARE RECEIVING
BENEFITS TO BE ABLE TO DO A VERY
SIMPLE THING, RECEIVE FRUIT AND
VEGETABLES THAT COME TO THEIR
DOOR. WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE AS WE HAVE
A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A MOTION
AND DO EXACTLY THAT. YOU HAVE
ONE MORE ITEM, ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT, AB 3161. HEALTH AND CARE
FACILITIES. PATIENT SAFETY AND
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I
AUTHORED THIS BILL BECAUSE
BLACK, INDIGENOUS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR COMMUNITIES EXPERIENCE A
HIGHER RATES OF MEDICAL
MISDIAGNOSES AND PATIENT ADVERSE
EVENTS WHEN COMPARED TO WHITE
PATIENTS. THIS BILL REQUIRES
HOSPITAL SAFETY PLANS TO INCLUDE
A PROCESS FOR ADDRESSING RACISM
AND DISCRIMINATION AND ITS
IMPACTS ON PATIENT HEALTH AND
SAFETY, INCLUDING MONITORING
SOCIO DEMOGRAPHIC DISPARITIES
AND PATIENT SAFETY EVENTS.
DEVELOPING INTERVENTIONS TO
REMEDY KNOWN DISPARITIES, AND
ENCOURAGING FACILITY STAFF TO
REPORT SUSPECTED INSTANCES OF
RACISM AND DISCRIMINATION. THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES HOSPITALS TO
PROVIDE THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WITH DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
AFFECTED PATIENT WHEN REPORTING
ADVERSE EVENTS. WE CANNOT SOLVE
THE PROBLEMS OF RACIAL BIAS AND
DISPARITIES IN PATIENT SAFETY
EVENTS UNTIL WE ACTUALLY HAVE
REAL DATA ABOUT THE SCOPE OF THE
PROBLEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA, THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE THAT DATA.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY IS
VANESSA KAHENA REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK. YES, MA'AM. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, VANESSA
KAHENA WITH CP PUBLIC AFFAIRS IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK. PROUD SPONSORS AND
CO-SPONSORS OF AB 3161. THIS
BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A MECHANISM
TO TRACK RACISM AND
DISCRIMINATION IN HEALTH CARE,
WHILE ALSO SUPPORTING PATIENTS
AND ACCESSING JUSTICE. RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION AND IMPLICIT BIAS
PERSIST IN THE HEALTH CARE
INDUSTRY AND NEGATIVELY AFFECT
HEALTH OUTCOMES, AND THESE
CHALLENGES MAY LEAD TO SERIOUS
INJURY, MISDIAGNOSIS, OR EVEN
DEATH. WELL DOCUMENTED NATIONAL
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR ARE MUCH MORE LIKELY TO
EXPERIENCE PATIENT SAFETY EVENTS
THAN THEIR WHITE COUNTERPARTS.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS OVERSIGHT OF
FACILITIES AND IS REQUIRED TO
REVIEW ADVERSE PATIENT SAFETY
EVENTS. HOWEVER, IT IS NOT
COLLECTING THAT DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
OR SEXUAL ORIENTATION AND GENDER
IDENTITY INFORMATION IN
CONNECTION WITH THESE EVENTS. AB
3161 CREATES THE MECHANISM TO
COLLECT THAT DATA SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND THOSE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES. THIS IS PROBLEMATIC
HISTORICALLY IN TERMS OF
TRACKING WHO IN OUR STATE IS
BEING HARMED. UPDATING THE
INFORMATION COLLECTED WHILE ALSO
GETTING PATIENTS CLEAR
INFORMATION ON THE COMPLAINT IS
CURRENTLY PRETTY CONFUSING. SO
PUTTING THIS ALL TOGETHER GIVES
YOU A MUCH BETTER MECHANISM FOR
PATIENT SAFETY. BUT THEN ALSO
LOOKING AT SYSTEMIC INFORMATION
AB 3161 CAN'T END RACISM OR
DISCRIMINATION OR IMPLICIT BIAS,
BUT IT WILL GIVE US A MUCH
BETTER CONCEPT OF PATIENTS
AROUND THE STATE AND GIVING THEM
THE TOOLS TO ADDRESS PROBLEMATIC
ACTORS. FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA FOR HER LEADERSHIP. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? NAME, AFFILIATION,
POSITION ON THE MEASURE ONLY.
PLEASE THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
ALICE KESSLER I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US NEXT. SANDRA POOLE, ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM. SYMPHONY BARBIE, ON
BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. DYLAN
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT.
THANKS. YES, MA'AM. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON, CAROL GONZALEZ. WE
HAVE HISPANAS ORGANIZED FOR
POLITICAL EQUALITY AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR COMING TODAY. YES, MA'AM.
HI. GOOD AFTERNOON, BETH
MALINOWSKI WITH SEO CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS
HELLO. RACHEL BHAGWAT, ACLU,
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE.
JENNIFER ROBLES WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. BRING IT
BACK TO THE DAIS. MY COLLEAGUES,
ANY COMMENTS, QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS? SENATOR RUBIO? OF
COURSE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MR. CHAIR. AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS. I KNOW THAT I WAS
LISTENING, I MEAN, NOT ONLY
READING, BUT LISTENING TO WHAT
YOU WERE SAYING AND ALREADY
KNOW. NATIONAL RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT PEOPLE OF COLOR ARE
CONSTANTLY BEING ON THE LOSING
END OF THIS ISSUE. AND YOU KNOW,
I THINK COLLECTING DATA IS SUPER
IMPORTANT JUST TO REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHERE THE
DEFICIENCIES ARE AND WE CAN FIX
THE PROBLEM. SO THANK YOU BOTH.
AND I WANT TO BE ADDED AS A
COAUTHOR TO THIS BILL. SO
APPRECIATE YOU. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ANY OTHERS SEEING NO OTHERS
, MADAM CHAIR AGAIN, YOUR LUCKY
DAY. YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU.
THIS IS JUST A VERY SMART, BASIC
BILL THAT ALLOWS US TO BE ABLE
TO USE THE POWER OF DATA TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXTENT TO WHICH
BIAS AND RACIAL DISPARITIES
IMPACT OUR PATIENTS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I VOTE
. AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM,
WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND WE'LL
TAKE A VOTE ON THIS ONE AS WELL.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US, MADAM
CHAIR. NICE PRESENTATIONS. YES
NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER 11, A B2081.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVIES, SUBSTANCE
ABUSE RECOVERY AND TREATMENT
PROGRAMS. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK
YOU, HONORABLE CHAIR AND
SENATORS, I WANT TO START OUT BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON OUR
STAKEHOLDERS SO DILIGENTLY ON
THIS BILL. I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB 2081, WHICH RELATES
TO RESIDENTIAL TREATMENT
FACILITIES. MY STAFF AND I HAVE
WORKED HARD ON AMENDMENTS FOR
THIS BILL WITH ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE STAFF, AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE RECOMMENDATIONS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY REQUIRES
OPERATORS OF SUBSTANCE USE
TREATMENT FACILITIES TO INCLUDE
ON THEIR WEBSITE AND INTAKE
PAPERWORK, A DISCLOSURE THAT
WILL HELP LEAD PATIENTS TO THE
DHCS WEBSITE SO THEY MAY CHECK
FOR PRIOR VIOLATIONS OR EVEN SEE
IF THEIR LICENSE HAD BEEN
SUSPENDED AT ONE POINT. THIS CAN
BE GREATLY BENEFICIAL TO
PATIENTS BY EMPOWERING THEM TO
LOOK DEEPER INTO WHICH
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES OVERSEE
THEIR FACILITIES, THEY CAN LEARN
MORE ABOUT TREATMENT OPTIONS AND
PROTECTIONS GUARANTEED TO THEM.
AS A PATIENT. MY BILL WILL ALSO
EMPOWER DHS TO PENALIZE
FACILITIES. IF THEY DO NOT
INCLUDE THE DISCLOSURE, THE
PENALTY WOULD BE DETERMINED BY
DCS TO MAKE SURE IT'S CONSISTENT
WITH THEIR FINE STRUCTURE. AB
2081 IS INTENDED TO FURTHER
RAISE THE LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY WITHIN THE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
SYSTEM. SEEKING TREATMENT FOR
SUBSTANCE USE CAN BE TABOO AND,
AND AS LONG AS WE CONTINUE TO
LET BAD ACTORS RUN RAMPANT AND
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF PATIENTS IN
THIS SYSTEM, IT WILL STAY THAT
WAY. THERE ARE SO MANY STORIES
FROM PARENTS AND PATIENTS ABOUT
WHAT HAS GONE ON IN SOME OF
THESE FACILITIES, AND MOST ARE
UTTERLY HEARTBREAKING. WE ARE
LUCKY LEADERS IN THIS STATE AND
CAN HELP TO PREVENT THE LOSS AND
SADNESS THAT OCCURS IN SOME OF
OUR FACILITIES. WITH ME TODAY IS
CAROLYN GRINDER, REPRESENTING
THE AB 2081 SPONSORED THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES ONORABLE
CHAIR AND SENATORS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS CAROLYN
GRINDER, ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES, WE ARE
PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR THE AB 2081.
THIS COMMON SENSE LEGISLATION
WOULD REQUIRE A HIGHER STANDARD
OF TRANSPARENCY AND GREATER
PROTECTIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
SEEKING ALCOHOL AND SUBSTANCE
USE TREATMENT, SPECIFICALLY, AB
2081 WOULD REQUIRE A RECOVERY OR
TREATMENT FACILITIES TO PROVIDE
A DISCLOSURE TO THOSE SEEKING
CARE THAT THEY CAN CHECK THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WEBSITE TO CONFIRM THE
FACILITIES COMPLIANCE WITH STATE
LICENSING LAWS. COMPLIANCE WITH
THESE LAWS ADMINISTERED THROUGH
THE DEPARTMENT IS ESSENTIAL TO
SAFEGUARDING RESIDENTS
WELL-BEING AND MAINTAINING
QUALITY CARE. THIS MEASURE WOULD
ENSURE THAT THOSE SEEKING
TREATMENT KNOW WHAT VIOLATIONS,
IF ANY, HAVE OCCURRED WITHIN A
RECOVERY FACILITY AND WOULD HOLD
PROVIDERS ACCOUNTABLE BY MAKING
THIS INFORMATION MORE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE. BY MAKING THIS
RESOURCE MORE EASILY ACCESSIBLE,
AB 2081 EMPOWERS PATIENTS TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT
THEIR CARE. RESIDENTIAL RECOVERY
HOUSING PROVIDES A WIDE RANGE OF
BENEFITS TO SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
PRIORITIZE THEIR NEEDS OVER
PROFITS. WE HAVE A LONG HISTORY
AT CAL CITIES OF ATTEMPTING TO
PASS LEGISLATION TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY CITIES ABOUT
THE NEED FOR INCREASED
OVERSIGHT, TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ALCOHOL AND
DRUG TREATMENT FACILITIES
OPERATING IN OUR COMMUNITIES. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A PRACTICAL
STEP FORWARD AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
BEING HERE. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURE
ONLY, PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, SHARON GONSALVES, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF CARLSBAD
IN SUPPORT, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? OKAY. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE JOIN US IN
THE WELL AND THE TABLE IF YOU'D
LIKE.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS TRENT
MURPHY, AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES. WE'RE A PROFESSIONAL
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS THE
MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S PUBLICLY
FUNDED SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT NETWORK, WE'RE NOT
NECESSARILY OPPOSED TO THE
INTENT OF THE BILL. WE ALSO
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR THAT STATE
REGULATIONS AND LAW NEED TO
ENSURE THAT BAD ACTORS ARE NOT
ALLOWED IN THIS SPACE, SO THANK
YOU FOR SAYING THAT. BUT WE DO
DISAGREE THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
NEW REGULATIONS PLACED ON
LICENSED SUED SERVICES, THIS
BILL IN PARTICULAR IS
UNNECESSARY IN OUR OPINION,
BECAUSE CURRENT LAW AND THE
REGULATORY REGULATORY RULES
ALREADY COVER THE REQUIREMENTS
OUTLINED IN THIS LEGISLATION.
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE,
SPECIFICALLY SECTION 11 831.12,
ALREADY MANDATES LICENSED SEED
PROVIDERS TO DISCLOSE ON THEIR
WEBSITE AND IN ANY MARKETING OF
THEIR FACILITY, THEIR DC'S
LICENSE NUMBER AND THEIR
EXPIRATION DATE FOR THAT
LICENSE. THIS DISCLOSURE ON THE
WEBSITE INCLUDES A HYPERLINK
WHICH CONVENIENTLY TAKES A WEB
USER DIRECTLY TO DC'S FULL LIST
OF CERTIFIED AND LICENSED WSUD
TREATMENT PROVIDERS.
ADDITIONALLY THE SAME STATUTE
MANDATES SEED PROVIDERS TO
PROVIDE THEIR LICENSE AND
CERTIFICATION INFORMATION TO
ANYONE WHO INQUIRES ABOUT THE
FACILITY'S LICENSE THROUGH ANY
METHOD OF COMMUNICATION
REGARDING THE INTAKE PAPERWORK
PORTION OF THE BILL. SECTION
16,000 OF DC'S ALCOHOL AND OTHER
DRUG PROGRAM CERTIFICATION
STANDARDS ALREADY REQUIRES THAT
THE DISCLOSURE OF CLIENTS RIGHTS
AT THE TIME OF INTAKE, WHICH I
WON'T GIVE THE EXHAUSTIVE LIST,
BUT IN THAT CLIENT'S RIGHTS
PAPERWORK, IT INCLUDES THE RIGHT
OF EACH PERSON TO BE INFORMED OF
THE PROCEDURES TO FILE A
GRIEVANCE OR APPEAL A DISCHARGE
WITH DHS. CURRENT REGULATIONS
STATES THAT EACH NEW CLIENT MUST
REVIEW, SIGN, AND BE PROVIDED A
COPY OF THESE RIGHTS UPON
ADMISSION, AND THESE RIGHTS MUST
BE POSTED IN A VISIBLE LOCATION
FOR THE GENERAL PUBLIC AS WELL
AS NEW CLIENTS. SO IT IS OUR
OPINION THAT THE CURRENT LAW
ALREADY MANDATES TRANSPARENCY
AND PUBLIC ACCESS TO LICENSING
INFORMATION FOR WSUD PROVIDERS,
AND ADDING ANOTHER LAYER OF
REQUIREMENTS IS REDUNDANT AND
IMPOSES UNNECESSARY
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDENS ON THE
SUED TREATMENT FACILITIES
WITHOUT OFFERING ANY ADDITIONAL
BENEFIT TO THE PUBLIC. SO WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO
RECONSIDER THE NECESSITY OF THIS
BILL AND ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR JOINING US
TODAY. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE, LET'S
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
DAIS. COLLEAGUES, ANY COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS? SEEING
NONE. SOME MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. APPRECIATE IT.
AS SOON AS WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND
WE WILL ACCOMPLISH THE VOTE.
NICE PRESENTATION. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. SO, MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN, ITEM NUMBER TEN AB
2063, HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY. GOOD
TO SEE YOU AGAIN. NICE TO SEE
YOU AGAIN, MR. CHAIRMAN, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, I
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, AS
DETAILED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS, AB 2063 EXTENDS THE
SUNSET DATE FOR A Kò PILOT
PROGRAM DELAYED BY THE PANDEMIC.
THIS PILOT PROGRAM INTEGRATES
RISK BEARING PROVIDERS WITH
SELF-FUNDED EMPLOYER PLANS USING
CAPITATED PAYMENT MECHANISMS TO
REDUCE HEALTH CARE COSTS. THIS
BILL PROPOSES A TWO YEAR
EXTENSION TO PROPERLY EVALUATE
THE IMPACT ON SERVICE SPEED,
HEALTH CARE COSTS AND PATIENT
OUTCOMES. THE EXTENSION ENSURES
THE PROGRAM CAN FULFILL ITS
OBJECTIVES DESPITE PANDEMIC
RELATED SETBACKS, REAFFIRMING
OUR COMMITMENT TO IMPROVING
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE, REDUCE
COSTS AND MEETING COMMUNITY
NEEDS DURING THESE CHALLENGING
TIMES, I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE AND JOINING ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT AND ALSO TO
ADDRESS ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
OR LARA JOSH, THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS VÀ
AND BILL BARCELONA FROM
AMERICANS, AMERICA'S PHYSICIAN
GROUPS. GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD BEFORE SPEAKING AND
PROCEED WHEN READY. THERE WE GO.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE THE SAME
PERSON. OKAY WELL, RED IS
CONFUSING. ALL RIGHT. HI. I'M
LARA JOSH, THE GENERAL MANAGER
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS. VIVA.
ROTH AND DISTINGUISHED MEMBERS
OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE. THANK YOU
FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY TO TALK
ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT BILL. VIVA
IS A NONPROFIT TRUST THAT WAS
FOUNDED IN 1993 AS A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN LABOR AND MANAGEMENT TO
ADDRESS THE RISING HEALTH CARE
COSTS OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES STATEWIDE. BY LAW, OUR
VEBA FUNDS CAN ONLY BE USED FOR
THE BENEFIT OF OUR TRUST
MEMBERS. UNLIKE OTHER HEALTH
PLANS, NO ONE'S PROFITING. THERE
IS NO DISTRIBUTION OF EARNINGS
AND EXCESS RESERVES ARE NOT
RETURNED TO THE EMPLOYERS. THEY
HAVE TO BE REINVESTED INTO THE
MEMBERS OF THE TRUST PROGRAM. WE
SERVE OVER 100,000 MEMBERS,
160,000 MEMBERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, WHICH INCLUDES
TEACHERS, CUSTODIANS, BUS
DRIVERS AND THE OTHER DIVERSE
EMPLOYEES WHO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE WERE HONORED TO
SELECT THE FIRST OF ITS KIND,
PILOT MADE POSSIBLE BY AB 1124,
WHICH FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE WAS A
HUGE STEP FORWARD AND ACTUALLY
GIVING US TRANSPARENCY INTO OUR
HEALTH CARE EXPENSES. WE
CURRENTLY SPEND OVER $1 BILLION
ON HEALTH CARE PREMIUMS AND HAVE
LIMITED VISIBILITY INTO THE
UNDERLYING CONTRACTS AND
EXPENSES. UNDER THE PILOT, WE
WERE ABLE TO LAUNCH A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM THAT IT
HAS EXTENSIVE MEMBER
PROTECTIONS. ON JANUARY 1ST, AND
WE'VE ENROLLED 5000 MEMBERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. WE'RE ALREADY
SEEING SAVINGS IN THE PROGRAM
WITH GREAT OUTCOMES, AND MEMBER
SATISFACTION HAS BEEN HIGH WITH
NO COMPLAINTS RECEIVED. OUR
LAUNCH DATE WAS DELAYED TWO
YEARS DUE TO THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC, SO WE'RE SEEKING A TWO
YEAR EXTENSION TO ENSURE WE CAN
GET COMPLETE DATA OF THE PILOT.
BY GRANTING THE EXTENSION, WE
AVOID DISRUPTING MEMBER CARE,
ALLOW EVALUATION OF THE COST
SAVINGS, PATIENT OUTCOMES AND
REALLY SATISFACTION. SO
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS VÀ SUPPORTS
THIS BILL, AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. BILL
BARCELONA WITH AMERICA'S
PHYSICIAN GROUPS. WE'RE PROUD TO
PARTNER WITH CAL SCHOOLS VIVA ON
THIS PILOT, I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE PROVIDERS
WHO ARE INVOLVED IN THE PILOT IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY. FOR THE FIRST
YEAR OF OPERATION, WE HAVE RATED
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL AND RADY
CHILDREN'S MEDICAL GROUP, THE
LARGEST, PRIMARY CARE CHILDREN'S
SPECIALTY MEDICAL GROUP IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, WE HAVE
UCSD MEDICAL GROUP AND HOSPITAL
SYSTEM, AND WE HAVE TWO OF THE
SHARP, GROUPS SHARP STEELY,
WHICH HAS BEEN IN OPERATION FOR
OVER 100 YEARS IN THE SAN DIEGO
REGION, AND SHARP COMMUNITY
MEDICAL GROUP, AS WELL AS THE
SHARP HOSPITALS. THESE ARE SOME
OF THE BEST PROVIDERS IN THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES. THEY'RE
PROUD TO PARTICIPATE WITH VIVA
ON THIS, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE TRANSPARENCY THAT THIS WILL
GENERATE AROUND COST AND
QUALITY, TO INFORM OUR HEALTH
POLICY IN THE STATE AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SIR. THANK YOU
BOTH FOR JOINING US. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? OKAY. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? COME ON
DOWN. HI. HOW ARE YOU, GUY? GOOD
. SORRY, GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, ROBERT
BOYKIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS.
REGRETTABLY, IN OPPOSITION TO AB
2063, WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND THEIR
EFFORTS TO PROMOTE INNOVATION IN
HEALTH CARE. HOWEVER, WE
CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
ALLOWING NEW RISK BEARING
ARRANGEMENTS FOR PROVIDERS
OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF VÆ. KNOX Kò
ONLY STATE LICENSED HEALTH PLAN,
CALIFORNIA KNOCKS TÍNH LICENSE
PLAN. HEALTH PLANS ARE TIGHTLY
REGULATED AND COMPLY WITH A WIDE
ARRAY OF REQUIREMENTS THAT
PROTECT THE MARKET AND HEALTH
CARE SERVICE CUSTOMERS, AMONG
OTHER THINGS. FULLY LICENSED
HEALTH PLANS MUST MEET STRINGENT
SOLVENCY REQUIREMENTS, ENSURE
TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE, IMPLEMENT
CUSTOMER GRIEVANCE PROCESSES,
AND PARTICIPATE IN INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL REVIEWS. WE FEEL THIS
BILL WILL ALLOW AN ARRANGEMENT
THAT DOES NOT PROVIDE THE
IMPORTANT CUSTOMER CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS THAT A LICENSED
HEALTH PLAN MUST EXTEND TO
ENROLLEES, AND FOR THOSE
REASONS, FOR THAT REASON, I
SHOULD SAY WE ASK YOU FOR A NO
VOTE ON AB 2063. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION? NAME,
AFFILIATION, POSITION ON THE
MEASURE, PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. MATT AKIN WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. JACKIE
ONIS, ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS,
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON OKAY.
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
DAIS. MY COLLEAGUES, ANY
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS
SEEING NONE. SUMMARY. MEMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS, IN CLOSING,
YOU KNOW THIS BUILDS ON WE
PASSED THIS WITH AB 1124 BACK IN
I BELIEVE IT WAS 2020. BUT WE
JUST AND IT WAS GREAT PASSED THE
ASSEMBLY PASSED THE SENATE WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW. BUT WE
ESSENTIALLY LOST TWO YEARS
BECAUSE OF COVID. SO FOR ALL THE
PURPOSES THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY PASSED THIS, WE
WANT TO GET THIS DATA. IT'S A
PILOT PROGRAM. I THINK IT WAS
WELL ENUNCIATED BY THE TWO
WITNESSES. BUT WE WANT TO GET
THIS DATA IN AND WE LOST TWO
YEARS THROUGH NO FAULT OF ANYONE
BECAUSE OF COVID. SO THIS WILL
MAKE UP FOR THAT AND MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IT'S RENDERED WHOLE.
SO WITH THAT EXPLANATION, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. AS SOON AS
WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE A
MOTION AND WE WILL DO JUST THAT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. NICE
PRESENTATION. IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOWENTHAL HERE? ITEM NUMBER 12,
AB 20 105 COVERAGE FOR PANDAS
AND PANS. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB 2105, WHICH REQUIRES A HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLAN, CONTRACT OR
HEALTH INSURANCE POLICY ISSUED,
AMENDED OR RENEWED ON OR AFTER
JANUARY FIRST, 2025 TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE FOR TREATMENT OF
PEDIATRIC AUTOIMMUNE,
NEUROPSYCHIATRIC DISORDER
ASSOCIATED WITH STREPTOCOCCAL
INFECTIONS OR PANDAS, AND
PEDIATRIC ACUTE ONSET NEUROPSYCH
PATRICK SYNDROME, OR PANS,
PRESCRIBED OR ORDERED BY A
PHYSICIAN OR SURGEON, AS DEFINED
BY CURRENT CLINICAL PRACTICE
GUIDELINES PUBLISHED IN PEER
REVIEW MEDICAL LITERATURE OR PUT
FORTH BY ORGANIZATIONS COMPOSED
OF EXPERT TREATING CLINICIANS. I
WOULD LIKE TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. PANDAS AND PANS ARE
INFLAMMATORY DISEASES OF THE
BRAIN THAT RESULT IN SUDDEN
ONSET, DEVASTATING BEHAVIORAL
AND NEURO NEUROLOGICAL
DYSFUNCTION THAT USUALLY OCCUR
AFTER A TRIGGERING INFECTION.
THESE DISORDERS ARE THOUGHT TO
BE CAUSED BY AUTOANTIBODIES
GENERATED AFTER THE INFECTION
THAT MISTAKENLY ATTACKED THE
BRAIN. ANTIBIOTICS AND ORAL
ANTI-INFLAMMATORY MEDICATION
HELP MOST CHILDREN, BUT A
MINORITY NEEDS STRONGER IMMUNE
MODULATING TREATMENTS, SUCH AS
INTRAVENOUS IMMUNOGLOBULIN OR
IVIG. DESPITE SITE PUBLISHED
PANDAS AND PANS TREATMENT
GUIDELINES THAT ESTABLISH THE
STANDARD OF CARE BACK IN 2017,
INSURERS HAVE CONTINUED TO
ADHERE TO THEIR OWN POLICY
STATEMENTS FORBIDDING
AUTHORIZATION OF IMMUNE FOCUSED
TREATMENTS LIKE IVIG, AND AS A
RESULT, TREATMENTS ARE ROUTINELY
DENIED. EARLY AND EXPEDIENT
TREATMENT OF PANDAS AND PANDAS
IS ESSENTIAL IN ORDER TO PREVENT
LONG TERM AND POTENTIALLY LIFE
THREATENING IMPACTS OF THESE
CONDITIONS. PATIENTS SEEKING
IMMUNE MODULATING TREATMENT FOR
ACUTE PANDAS AND PANS ARE
FREQUENTLY DENIED AUTHORIZATION
FOR THESE TREATMENTS BY
INSURERS, AND MUST SEEK
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE. WHILE THE IMR PROCESS IS
EFFECTIVE, DECISIONS ARE
TYPICALLY RENDERED WITHIN 30
DAYS OF QUALIFICATION, MEANING
THAT INSURERS THE INSURED MUST
FIRST RECEIVE A DENIAL FROM
THEIR INSURER, FILE A REQUEST
FOR AN INDEPENDENT MEDICAL
REVIEW, AND WAIT FOR A DECISION
TO UPHOLD OR OVERTURN THE
INSURERS DENIAL. UNFORTUNATELY
MTLY THIS TIMELINE IS SIMPLY TOO
LONG FOR CHILDREN SUFFERING FROM
PANDAS AND PANS AND IS
FREQUENTLY LEADING TO KIDS
RECEIVING TREATMENT LONG AFTER
CURRENT TREATMENT GUIDELINES
RECOMMEND THAT. ACCORDING TO THE
CLINICAL MANAGEMENT OF PEDIATRIC
ACUTE ONSET NEUROPSYCHIATRIC
SYNDROME, EARLY CARE FOR PANDAS
AND PANS PATIENTS IS DEFINED AS
RECEIVING TREATMENT WITHIN TWO
WEEKS OF DIAGNOSIS. LATE CARE IS
DEFINED AS RECEIVING TREATMENT
WITHIN 2 TO 4 WEEKS OF DIAGNOSIS
, AND VERY DELAYED CARE IS
DEFINED AS RECEIVING TREATMENT
MORE THAN FOUR WEEKS AFTER
DIAGNOSIS. BASED ON PUBLISHED
CLINICAL TREATMENT GUIDELINES
FOR PANDAS AND PANS, DENIALS ARE
FREQUENTLY RESULTING IN VERY
DELAYED CARE FOR PANDAS AND
PANDAS PATIENTS, WHICH RESULTS
IN WORSE HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
PATIENTS AND THE NEED FOR LONG
TERM CARE, WHICH RESULTS IN
GREATER COST TO PATIENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES, INSURERS, AND TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THEY
SAY THAT TIMING IS EVERYTHING,
AND IN THE CASE OF PANDAS AND
PANS, IT COULDN'T BE MORE TRUE.
EARLY AND EXPEDIENT ACCESS TO
THE TREATMENTS IS CRUCIAL TO THE
EFFECTIVE TREATMENT OF PANDAS
AND PANS. IN ORDER TO AVOID
DEBILITATING SYMPTOMS,
POTENTIALLY PERMANENT
NEUROLOGICAL DAMAGE, SOMETIMES
FATAL OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED WITH
THESE DISORDERS, AB 2105 WILL
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES WHO ARE CONFRONTED WITH
THESE DISORDERS DO NOT
EXPERIENCE UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN
TREATMENT THAT CAN LEAD TO
DISASTROUS AND TRAGIC OUTCOMES.
IT IS MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE
DOCTOR ANGELA TANG AND SHERRY
STRELSIN, WHO ARE BOTH MOTHERS
OF CHILDREN SUFFERING WITH PANS
AND ARE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2105. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US. I'LL
ASK YOU TO IDENTIFY YOURSELVES
FOR THE RECORD BEFORE SPEAKING.
TRY TO KEEP IT TO ABOUT SIX
MINUTES TOTAL, I REALIZE YOU
HAVE STORIES TO TELL AND WE WANT
TO HEAR THEM SO PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN READY. OKAY. THANK YOU,
CHAIR ROTH AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS SHERRY
STOLESON. I'M A FORMER PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER, AND I'M ALSO THE
MOM OF A 14 YEAR OLD BOY WITH
PANS AND PANDAS. OUR GRAVITY
DEFYING KID WAS FEARLESS AND
CHANNELED HIS STRENGTH, AGILITY,
INTELLIGENCE, AND COORDINATION
INTO SKATEBOARDING, PARKOUR,
GYMNASTICS, SKIING AND SOCCER.
HIS SYMPTOMS BEGAN IN JANUARY OF
2017, BUT TOOK ALMOST TWO YEARS
TO DIAGNOSE AND TREAT. DELAYED
TREATMENT CAUSED HIS CONDITION
TO PROGRESS TO THE POINT HE
COULD NO LONGER TIE HIS
SHOELACES, HOLD HIS HOLD HIS
PENCIL, OR FINISH A SENTENCE
WITHOUT PAINFUL VOCAL TICS, OR
WALK ACROSS OUR HALLWAY FLOOR,
LET ALONE ATTEND SCHOOL. DUE TO
CRIPPLING OCD, ANXIETY AND
COGNITIVE DECLINES, INCLUDING
IMPAIRED SPEECH AND THE ABILITY
TO READ AND WRITE. WHEN JAKE WAS
YOUNGER, HE DREAMED OF BECOMING
AN ARCHITECT, BUT NOW WE'RE
UNSURE WHAT HIS FUTURE HOLDS.
AFTER YEARS OF ACADEMIC LOSS.
THERE ARE MANY PANS, PANDAS,
SURVIVORS, STORIES YOU'VE HEARD
OR WILL HEAR. THEY ARE THE LUCKY
ONES WHO RECEIVE TIMELY
TREATMENT. THEY'LL GO ON TO LIVE
NORMAL AND OFTEN EXTRAORDINARY
LIVES. THE KIND OF LIFE I
ENVISION FOR MY SON. HIS
CONDITION IS NOW CHRONIC AND
WILL REQUIRE INVASIVE LONG TERM
IMMUNOTHERAPIES. HIS PHYSICAL
GROWTH HAS BEEN IMPACTED, HIS
PUBERTY IS DELAYED AND HORMONAL
INTERVENTION IS REQUIRED. MANY
TIMES WE FEARED WE LOSE HIM
ENTIRELY. INSURANCE DENIALS ARE
COSTLY. IF YOU ADD UP THE
MEDICAL BILLS WE'VE SPENT NEARLY
$600,000. HOWEVER OUR GREATEST
EXPENSE IS TIME. MARCH OF 2020
THROUGH AUGUST OF 2023 WERE
UNDOUBTEDLY THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
WHEN THE NEUROPSYCHIATRIC
SYMPTOMS WERE SO SEVERE, MY SON
COULDN'T INTERACT WITH ANY
FAMILY MEMBERS, INCLUDING HIS
TWO YOUNGER BROTHERS WHO
IDOLIZED HIM AND WERE ROBBED OF
THEIR BEST FRIEND. WE LOST 1278
DAYS WITH JAKE. WE WILL NEVER
GET THOSE DAYS BACK. HE WILL
NEVER GET BACK. THE LAST FIVE
YEARS OF HIS CHILDHOOD AND ALL
THE FRIENDSHIPS, RELIGIOUS AND
HOLIDAY GATHERINGS, SUMMER SPENT
AT CAMP AND SCHOOL, PROMOTIONS
THAT COME WITH THEM AT THIS
STAGE OF SEVERITY, EXPERTS AT
UCLA RECOMMEND NEXT YEAR
TREATMENT ALL DENIED BY OUR
INSURANCE COMPANY. AFTER BEING
CODED AS PANDAS IN MY HANDS, I'M
HOLDING OUR MOST RECENT DENIAL
DATED MAY 7TH, 2024, STATING THE
MEMBERS PLASMAPHERESIS WAS
DENIED IN AS EXPERIMENTAL AND
INVESTIGATION FOR PANDAS.
THEREFORE THE INPATIENT STAY FOR
THIS PROCEDURE IS DENIED AS WELL
. IN OTHER WORDS, OUR SON'S
BOARD CERTIFIED PEDIATRIC
HEMATOLOGIST ONCOLOGIST FROM A
RENOWNED RESEARCH UNIVERSITY
HOSPITAL IN CALIFORNIA DEEMS
THIS TREATMENT A MEDICAL
NECESSITY. BUT OUR INSURANCE
COMPANY DOES NOT. WHICH BEGS THE
QUESTION WHO HAS THE PATIENT'S
BEST INTEREST AT HEART?
MASSACHUSETTS AND 11 OTHER
STATES LIST PANDAS AS A COVERED
BENEFIT AND PROVIDE THE
TREATMENT MY SON AND COUNTLESS
OTHERS MEDICALLY NEED AND
DESERVE. WHAT IS A CHILD'S LIFE
WORTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA? CERTAINLY, THE PENNY
IT WOULD COST TO ENACT AB 2105.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US TODAY. YES,
MA'AM. THANK YOU SO MUCH. MY
NAME IS DOCTOR ANGELA TANG. FIVE
YEARS AGO, PAN STRUCK DOWN MY 15
YEAR OLD. MY HEALTHY SOCCER
PLAYER COULD NO LONGER WALK MY
STRAIGHT-A STUDENT COULDN'T
WRITE. HE SPAT OUT FOOD IF
INTRUSIVE THOUGHTS STRUCK AND HE
NEEDED ME AT HIS SIDE. EVEN
DURING HIS TORTURED SLEEP. WE
DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL, WORK AND
LIFE WITH TWO DOCTOR PARENTS. MY
SON GOT EVERY ORAL MEDICINE
RECOMMENDED IN THE 2017
TREATMENT GUIDELINES BY EXPERTS
AT STANFORD AND HARVARD AND
OTHER OTHER UNIVERSITIES, WHEN
HE COULD NO LONGER DRINK, HE WAS
SCHEDULED FOR A FEEDING TUBE.
THE GUIDELINES SAY THAT THE NEXT
MEDICINE TO TRY WAS IVIG, BUT
POLICIES BY ANTHEM, AETNA AND
OTHERS SAY THAT IVIG IS
EXPERIMENTAL, UNPROVEN AND NOT
MEDICALLY NECESSARY. LUCKILY, I
WORK FOR A LARGE MEDICAL GROUP
ISSUING AUTHORIZATIONS AND
DENIALS FOR THE LAST 15 YEARS
AND MY CONNECTIONS GOT HIM IVIG
WITH IMPROVEMENT WITHIN A WEEK.
NO FEEDING TUBE NEEDED TODAY
HE'S OFF MEDICINES AND HE'S A
COLLEGE PRE-MED NEARBY AND ONE
DAY HE MAY BE YOUR DOCTOR. MY
SON GOT IVIG SEVEN WEEKS FROM
ONSET. ACCORDING TO THESE
GUIDELINES, PAST FOUR WEEKS IS
VERY DELAYED CARE. BUT OF THE
HUNDREDS OF CASES THAT I'VE
SEEN, INCLUDING AT THE STANFORD
PANS CLINIC, WHERE I'M NOW AN
ADJUNCT CLINICAL ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR, NOT ONE HAS RECEIVED
IVIG FASTER THAN MY SON. THE
NORM IS MONTHS TO YEARS OF BRAIN
INFLAMMATION BEFORE INSURANCE
AGREES TO PAY OR PARENTS SELL
OFF ASSETS TO PAY, OR KIDS GET
INSTITUTIONALIZED OR DIE LIKE
THE SEVEN CHILDREN WHOSE BRAINS
ARE NOW DONATED TO GEORGETOWN
FOR RESEARCH. THREE WERE IN THE
LAST YEAR WHILE WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON OUR BILL, MY OPINIONS
ARE MY OWN. AS AN INSURANCE
INSIDER, PARENT AND PANS
RESEARCHER TODAY, I MAKE GOOD ON
THE OATH THAT I TOOK TO BECOME A
DOCTOR. WHEN I ASKED YOU TO
PROTECT THE YOUTH WHO LACK
DOCTOR PARENTS. SOME SAY THAT
EXISTING REGULATIONS WHERE
INSURERS USE BLANKET POLICIES BY
NAMELESS EMPLOYEES WHO'VE NEVER
TREATED PATIENTS TO
AUTOMATICALLY AND UNIVERSALLY
DENY IVIG, PLASMAPHERESIS AND
RITUXIMAB ARE SUFFICIENT FOR
THIS URGENT DIAGNOSIS. PLEASE
CONSIDER IF INSURER DEFINITIONS
OF MEDICAL NECESSITY SHOULD
VIOLATE PEER REVIEWED CLINICAL
PRACTICE GUIDELINES, BY WHICH AB
2105 DEFINES MEDICAL NECESSITY.
LET'S STOP INSURERS PASSING THE
BUCK TO TAXPAYERS IN SPECIAL ED.
UNEMPLOYMENT AND DISABILITY AB
2105 COST $7,000 TO AN ACT AND
UNDER A PENNY IN INSURANCE
PREMIUMS. TODAY, I GIVE VOICE TO
THE YOUTH WHOSE BRAINS LIE AT
GEORGETOWN, OAN, AND TO DOCTORS
SHACKLED IN THEIR ATTEMPTS TO
HELP. TODAY YOU CHOOSE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S KIDS? NO, FOR
JAKE'S PATH OR I FOR MY SON'S.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
YOU KNOW, HEALTH CARE SHOULD NOT
DEPEND ON WHO YOU KNOW. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN. OUR
KIDANI, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR. THANKS
FOR JOINING US. NEXT, PLEASE.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS,
DAVID GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA'S PHYSICIAN GROUPS, AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
VANESSA KHN, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. BRANDON
MARKEY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANKS AARON TAYLOR WITH
POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON BEHALF OF
MILLER WOMEN'S AND CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NORA LIN, ON BEHALF
OF CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT, MY
NAME IS KELLY STEVENS. I'M A
PARENT OF A TEN YEAR OLD BOY
SUFFERING FROM PANDAS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
JOINING US. DYLAN ELLIOTT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. HI. MY NAME IS JENSEN
TAUBENBERGER AND I'M A 15 YEAR
OLD WITH PANDAS. WE NEED YOUR
HELP. PLEASE SUPPORT THIS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR COMING. IT'S
MY BABY, AT LEAST HABSBURGER,
MOTHER. TEACHER. ENGINEERING
EMPATHY. MY 15 YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER, MY 11 YEAR OLD SON IS
ALSO THERE, SUFFERING FROM
PANDAS AND PANS, THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IT'S TIME FOR THIS CHANGE.
APPRECIATE YOU. THANKS FOR
COMING. YES SIR. JONATHAN BERGER
ALSO WITH ENGINEERING EMPATHY.
PARENT OF THEM. AMAZING FAMILY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. REALLY NEED IT. THANK
YOU. NEXT PLEASE. DOCTOR DENISE
CALAPRICE I'M A PANS RESEARCHER
AT STANFORD AND ALSO THE MOTHER
OF TWO YOUNG MEN WHO ARE LUCKY
ENOUGH TO BE DIAGNOSED THE DAY
THEIR SYMPTOMS OF PANS DEVELOPED
ARE TREATED EARLY AND WHO HAVE
LIVED LARGELY WITHOUT THE
DISEASE. NOW, STUDENTS AT
BERKELEY AND USC IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB 2105. THANK YOU.
YES, MA'AM. HI, I'M APRIL RONEY,
I'M A SECOND GRADE PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER AND MOM TO A PANS CHILD.
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB 205
FOR MY SON AIDEN, AND FOR ALL
CHILDREN WHO NEED ACCESS TO THIS
MEDICATION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. YES, MA'AM. HI, I'M KELLY
RILEY. I AM A MOM TO A FIERCE
PANDAS WHO HAS BEEN FIGHTING
THIS FOR FIVE YEARS. OF HER 11
YEARS ON THIS EARTH. I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE AYE. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT? ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE. LET'S BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE DESK. COLLEAGUES,
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS, CONCERNS.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, YOU KNOW, I HAVE TO SPEAK
ON THIS ISSUE. FIRST OF ALL, I
REMEMBER SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
IT'S BEEN BEFORE US AND, YOU
KNOW, HEARING THE STORIES OF ALL
CHILDREN JUST GOING THROUGH THIS
BREAKS MY HEART. ALSO AN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER. AND
SO I DO UNDERSTAND THE DELAY IN
EDUCATION, JUST LEARNING LOSSES
JUST NORMALLY IS HARD ON KIDS.
AND NOW ADDING THIS TO THEIR
YOUNG LIVES, THAT'S EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT. BUT I THINK HERE IS
THE KEY IS DELAYED CARE. I MEAN
FOR EVERY DAY THAT GOES BY,
WEEKS, MONTHS, IT'S JUST SO
DETRIMENTAL TO A CHILD AND NOT
ONLY, LIKE I SAID, TO LIVING A
HEALTHY LIFE, BUT ALSO, YOU
KNOW, THEIR FUTURE, THEIR
LEARNING. AND SO I COMMEND BOTH
OF YOU AS PARENTS TO, TO REALLY
FIGHT AND CONTINUE THIS FIGHT.
I'M DISAPPOINTED THAT I THINK WE
PASSED IT AND IT DIDN'T GET TO
THE FINISH LINE, IN PREVIOUS
YEARS. AND SO I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT AND I KNOW HOW HARD
BECAUSE AS A TEACHER, FOR 20
YEARS, I'VE KNOWN I'VE DEALT
WITH PARENTS, WITH CHILDREN,
WITH JUST SO MANY OTHER AILMENTS
AND SITUATIONS WHERE IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR A PARENT TO
NAVIGATE. SO I CAN ONLY IMAGINE
HOW HARD IT IS FOR BOTH OF YOU.
AND AS A RESEARCHER AND IN THE
THROES OF THIS ISSUE, YOU KNOW,
I HAVE TO SAY I COMMEND YOU FOR
GETTING THAT SERVICE RIGHT AWAY
TO YOUR CHILD, BECAUSE I HAVE
REMEMBER, JUST SPEAKING TO
PARENTS WHO AGAIN, THAT DELAYED
CARE IS KEY HERE. WE CAN'T
CONTINUE TO WAIT BECAUSE EVERY
DAY IS JUST SO HARMFUL FOR THE
CHILDREN. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ADVOCACY. AND AGAIN, I WANT TO
BE ADDED AS A COAUTHOR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR. DID I
SEE SOMEONE ELSE? SENATOR
MENGIBAR THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, I REALLY WANT
TO COMMEND YOUR CONTINUOUS
PERSEVERANCE TO THIS. YOU KNOW,
YOU CAN IMAGINE WE PROBABLY HAVE
SIMILAR BILLS THAT WE CONTINUE
TO BRING UP BECAUSE THEY'RE JUST
AND THEY'RE THE RIGHT THING TO
DO. AND WE SHOULDN'T PUT A PRICE
TAG AS A BARRIER TO DO WHAT IS
RIGHT FOR COVERAGE, ESPECIALLY
FOR OUR KIDS. I WANT TO THANK
THE ADVOCATES FOR COMING TO
SHARE YOUR STORY. I ALWAYS GET
REALLY UPSET THAT WE FORCE
PEOPLE OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES TO COME UP HERE AND
LITERALLY BEG US TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE COVER THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE AT
BARE MINIMUM, COVERING. RIGHT.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SEN. LIMÓN.
THANK YOU. AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY FOR COMING
FORWARD, FOR SHARING THEIR
STORIES, BUT ALSO THE AUTHOR.
YOU HAVE A GREAT AUTHOR THAT'S
NOT GIVING UP, AND THIS IS SOME
OF THE WORK THAT'S NEEDED IN THE
LEGISLATURE. SO THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR. THANK YOU, TO EACH OF
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR STORIES,
THIS IS REALLY DIFFICULT, AND
CERTAINLY WE APPRECIATE THAT
THIS IS AN EFFORT THAT THERE'S A
STRONG COMMITMENT TO. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY ANY OTHER COMMENTS
SEEING NONE. SO REMEMBER, YOU
MAY CLOSE, I, I'M GET A LITTLE
EMOTIONAL ON THIS TOPIC,
BECAUSE, THIS IS SUCH A SPECIAL
COMMUNITY OF FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN
TREMENDOUSLY PATIENT WITH THE
SYSTEM THAT, HAS NOT BEEN KIND
TO THEM THUS FAR. THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT I CAN SAY
TO YOU IS THAT WE ARE A BIT OF
THE OUTLIER HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AT THIS POINT, AS ONE OF THE
WITNESSES TESTIFY TO, THERE'S
ALREADY A DOZEN STATES THAT HAVE
THIS IN PLACE. AS A MATTER OF
FACT, IT WAS SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR OF COLORADO ONLY A WEEK
AGO IN THAT STATE. AND THERE'S A
DOZEN MORE THAT HAVE THIS IN
PLAY. AND IF WE LOOK AT THIS BY
ANY MEASURE, IT MAKES SENSE.
THESE FAMILIES, AS YOU HEARD,
ARE DEBILITATED AND CANNOT WORK
WHILE THEIR CHILDREN ARE GOING
THROUGH THESE SYMPTOMS. AND SO
THEY RELY ON STATE SOCIAL SAFETY
NET SERVICES. SO WE'RE PAYING NO
MATTER WHAT WE ARE PAYING, WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SIR. AS
SOON AS WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM,
WE WILL TAKE A MOTION AND WE
WILL TAKE THE VOTE. THANKS FOR
ATTENDING AND NICE PRESENTATION.
WE HAVE SIX NOW. OKAY. WE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. PLEASE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. SENATOR ROTH
HERE. ROTH HERE. WHEN? HERE.
WHEN HERE. GLASER GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ HERE. GROVE HURTADO.
LIMÓN. HERE LIMON. HERE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. HERE. RUBIO.
RUBIO. PRESENT SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WIENER WE HAVE A QUORUM.
I WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION. IS THERE A
MOTION? I'LL MOVE THE BILL MOVED
BY SENATOR RUBIO, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SORRY. SENATOR ROTH, A
ROTH I WHEN I WHEN I GLASER.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HURTADO LIMÓN LIMON I MENGIBAR I
MENGIBAR I RUBIO I RUBIO I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER VOTE
IS SIX ZERO WILL HOLD A ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU ALL. THANK YOU. NEXT ITEM,
ITEM NUMBER 14. LET'S SEE. 14.
NO, 1514 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN AB 2297 HOSPITAL AND
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN FAIR PRICING
POLICIES. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
READY. THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR.
AND SENATORS. THANK YOU, MEDICAL
DEBT IS A SIGNIFICANT DRIVER OF
BANKRUPTCY, POVERTY AND RACIAL
INEQUALITIES. OVER A THIRD OF
CALIFORNIANS REPORT HAVING
MEDICAL DEBT AND HOSPITAL DEBT
ALONE MAKES UP OVER 70% OF ALL
MEDICAL DEBT. THIS IS, OF
COURSE, NONVOLUNTARY DEBT. IT'S
NOT LIKE PEOPLE WANT TO GO TO
THE HOSPITAL OR WANT TO GO TO
THE DOCTOR. IT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU HAVE TO DO TO LIVE, WHILE WE
IN 2006, CALIFORNIA CREATED THE
HOSPITAL FAIR PRICING ACT TO
PROTECT PATIENTS. AND MANY OF
YOU MIGHT RECALL OUR RECENT
UPDATES TO THE ACT IN 2021,
INCLUDING MY BILL, AB 1020.
WHILE PATIENT PROTECTIONS WE PUT
INTO LAW ARE WORKING, WE'RE ALSO
LEARNING OF AREAS WHERE WE NEED
TO STRENGTHEN THE LAW. AB 2297
DOES THE FOLLOWING. IT DEFINES
CHARITY CARE, DISTINGUISHING IT
FROM DISCOUNTED CARE OR
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. IT
CLARIFIES THAT HOSPITALS MUST
REVIEW APPLICATIONS FOR CHARITY
CARE OR DISCOUNTED CARE WITHOUT
ARBITRARY DEADLINES. A LOT OF
TIMES WHEN PEOPLE ARE DISCHARGED
FROM THE HOSPITAL, THEY'RE IN
BAD SHAPE, AND FOR THEM TO
EXPECT TO BE TO KNOW ABOUT
WHAT'S AVAILABLE TO THEM, MAYBE
THEY FIND OUT 1 OR 2 MONTHS
LATER THAT THEY COULD HAVE
GOTTEN CHARITY CARE. THEY'RE LOW
INCOME IN THE HOSPITAL SAYS, OH,
SORRY, YOU ONLY HAD TWO WEEKS TO
APPLY. THAT SHOULDN'T BE
ALLOWED. IT PROHIBITS THE USE OF
LIENS ON PROPERTY TO COLLECT
UNPAID MEDICAL BILLS FROM
FINANCIALLY ELIGIBLE PATIENTS.
AND YES, PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
STILL CAN HAVE THEIR HOUSES
TAKEN AWAY BECAUSE OF UNPAID
MEDICAL DEBT. AND FINALLY, IT
ELIMINATES THE CONSIDERATION OF
ASSETS FROM ELIGIBILITY
CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT MEDI-CAL
RULES. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT THESE PATIENT
PROTECTIONS APPLY ONLY TO
UNINSURED AND UNDERINSURED
PATIENTS WHO HAVE AN INCOME
UNDER 400% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE. SO THESE ARE OUR
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. FOR
PATIENTS WITH LIMITED RESOURCES,
MEDICAL DEBT CAN BE DEVASTATING.
PUTTING THEM AT RISK OF HOUSING
INSTABILITY AND FINANCIAL RUIN,
AS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS ON PAGE
SEVEN, WE HAVE AMENDMENTS THAT
FURTHER CLARIFY THE ASSETS THAT
A HOSPITAL MAY CONSIDER WHEN
DETERMINING A PATIENT'S
ELIGIBILITY FOR FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE. THIS LANGUAGE
ADDRESSES A NUMBER OF THE
CONCERNS OUTLINED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
I WANT TO THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR,
AND YOUR STAFF, FOR YOUR WORK.
AS WE'VE CONTINUED TO REFINE THE
LANGUAGE OF THE BILL TO
STRENGTHEN THE SOCIAL SAFETY NET
FOR PATIENTS IN NEED. WITH THAT,
I WOULD REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY ARE
LINDA WEI FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY AND
CHRISTINE SMITH FROM HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS. YES.
AND PLEASE PROCEED. PROCEED WHEN
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON. LINDA WEI
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY, PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB
2297 AS A LEGAL AID SUPPORT
CENTER. OUR LOCAL PROGRAMS WORK
WITH CLIENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE, AND I'M HERE TO SHARE ONE
STORY. HUMBERTO CRUZ SOUGHT HELP
FROM NEIGHBORHOOD LEGAL SERVICES
OF LOS ANGELES DUE TO MEDICAL
DEBT ACCRUED FROM THE BIRTH AND
RESULTING ICU STAY OF HIS AND
HIS WIFE'S FIRSTBORN. IN 2010,
AT QUEEN OF THE VALLEY HOSPITAL
IN WEST COVINA, DESPITE HAVING
WHAT HE BELIEVED TO BE ADEQUATE
EMPLOYER COVERAGE, THEY WERE
BLINDSIDED BY EXPENSES NOT
COVERED BY INSURANCE. THE
HOSPITAL FAILED TO INFORM THEM
ABOUT THE OPTION TO APPLY FOR
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE OR GUIDANCE
TO MANAGE THE DEBT, LEAVING THEM
WITH A BILL OF $19,200. BEFORE
THEY KNEW IT, THEIR ACCOUNT WAS
SENT TO COLLECTIONS AS A RESULT
OF UMBERTO'S INABILITY TO TAKE
TIME OFF FROM HIS NEW JOB TO
APPEAR IN COURT, A DEFAULT
JUDGMENT WAS ENTERED AGAINST
HIM. ULTIMATELY THEY WERE FORCED
TO SELL THEIR HOME TO THEIR
IN-LAWS, ONLY TO DISCOVER THAT
THE PROPERTY HAD A LIEN DUE TO
THE OUTSTANDING MEDICAL DEBT.
DESPITE THEIR BEST EFFORTS TO
MAKE PAYMENTS, THE COLLECTION
AGENCY SEIZED 17,000 FROM THE
SALE OF THEIR IN-LAWS HOME AND
PLACED LEVIES ON UMBERTO'S
PERSONAL BANK ACCOUNT. OVER THE
COURSE OF 12 YEARS, THE CRUZES
PAID NEARLY 23,000 TO THE
COLLECTION AGENCY, WHICH DRAINED
THEIR SAVINGS AND RESULTED IN
CREDIT CARD DEBT. UMBERTO'S
STORY HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL, SPECIFICALLY THE
PROVISION TO PROHIBIT HOME LIENS
FOR FINANCIALLY QUALIFIED
PATIENTS, SO URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT, PLEASE, GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M CHRISTINE SMITH WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA FOR THE
STATEWIDE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION. WE ARE PROUD
TO SUPPORT AB 2297, WHICH WOULD
PROHIBIT THE USE OF HOME LIENS
IN THE COLLECTION OF UNPAID
HOSPITAL BILLS FROM FINANCIALLY
QUALIFIED PATIENTS. HOSPITALS
ARE CURRENTLY PROHIBITED FROM
PLACING LIENS ON A PATIENT'S
PRIMARY RESIDENCE, BUT DEBT
COLLECTORS ARE ALLOWED TO PLACE
LIENS ON A PATIENT'S HOME TO
COLLECT UNPAID HOSPITAL BILLS.
UNFORTUNATELY, PROPERTY LIENS
ARE REGULARLY USED TO COLLECT
UNPAID MEDICAL DEBT. A REVIEW OF
ASSESSOR DATA FOUND THAT IN LA
COUNTY ALONE, OVER 140 PROPERTY
LIENS WERE PLACED IN 2023 DUE TO
MEDICAL DEBT. THIS BILL WOULD
COMPLETELY PROHIBIT THIS
PRACTICE AGAINST FINANCIALLY
QUALIFIED PATIENTS, AS WAS THE
INTENT OF THE ORIGINAL LAW 18
YEARS AGO. IN ADDITION, THE BILL
WOULD ELIMINATE ASSET
CONSIDERATION AND FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE DETERMINATIONS TO
ALIGN WITH CURRENT MEDI-CAL
ELIGIBILITY RULES, SIMPLIFY THE
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE APPLICATION
PROCESS, AND HELP PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS SAVINGS FROM BEING
DEPLETED WHEN SEEKING CARE.
CALIFORNIANS NEED THEIR SAVINGS
TO PREVENT PROPERTY IN
RETIREMENT AND OLDER AGE,
PREVENT POVERTY AND RETIREMENT
OLDER AGE. MY APOLOGIES AS OF
2019, 7.4 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
AGES 25 TO 64 DO NOT HAVE ACCESS
TO AN EMPLOYER SPONSORED
RETIREMENT PLAN, AND NEARLY HALF
OF CALIFORNIA'S PRIVATE SECTORS
HAVE NO RETIREMENT ASSETS AT
ALL. FINALLY THE BILL WOULD
CLARIFY THAT HOSPITALS MUST
REVIEW FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
ELIGIBILITY AT ANY TIME AND
PROHIBIT APPLICATION DEADLINES
FOR FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE. WITH
MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF
CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCING
MEDICAL DEBT, THIS BILL PROVIDES
MUCH NEEDED RELIEF FROM LARGE
HOSPITAL BILLS FOR LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME CALIFORNIANS. WE
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURE ONLY
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON, JOHN
SKOGLUND WITH THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. VANESSA KHN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK HERE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BRYANT
MIRAMONTEZ WITH ASTHMA
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE, MARVIN
PINEDA, ON BEHALF OF THE
LEUKEMIA AND LYMPHOMA SOCIETY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE
. HELLO. RACHEL BHAGWAT, ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. GOOD
AFTERNOON, BETH MONOSKIS WITH
SEIU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. TOÀN
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? LEAD WITNESSES MAY
COME JOIN US IN THE WELL IF YOU
WISH. IF NOT, YOUR CALL. MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MEGAN LOPER,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION, I
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE, THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS, AND APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS. TO DATE, WE
CURRENTLY STILL REMAIN IN AN
OPPOSED, UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION, BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED DIALOG TO RESOLVE THE
REMAINING CONCERNS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE, LET'S BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE DAIS AND MY
COLLEAGUES, COLLEAGUES,
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS.
SEEING NONE, BILLS BEEN MOVED,
MOVED BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. BY
THE WAY, THE MOTION IS, DO PASS
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. SO
REMEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU. THIS WILL HELP TO PROTECT
SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS. AND I WOULD URGE AN
AYE VOTE. OKAY. BILLS BEEN MOVED
BY A BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. AND
LET'S CALL THE ROLL SENATOR ROTH
A ROTH. AYE WHEN? NO. WHEN. NO.
GLASER GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE HURTADO. LIMÓN LEMON. AYE.
MENGIBAR RUBIO. RUBIO. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ONE. WE'LL
HOLD THE MATTER OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU BOTH. THANK
YOU. I SEE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLORA, ITEM NUMBER 13, AB 2198.
HEALTH INFORMATION. PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, CHAIR AND MEMBERS, I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE MINUTES,
BUT PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2198.
AND I CERTAINLY ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AB 2198
EXEMPTS DENTAL AND VISION PLANS
FROM APPLICATION PROGRAMING
INTERFACE REQUIREMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA LAW THAT WAS MEANT TO
REPLICATE THE FEDERAL API
REGULATIONS AND WOULD FULLY
REPLICATE THE CENTER FOR
MEDICINE AND MEDICAL SERVICES
REGULATIONS AS ADOPTED INTO
CALIFORNIA LAW, WHEN TIME IS
RIGHT. WE SPOKE LAST BROUGH AND
HERE WITH ME IS MATT BECK. MR.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MATT BACK
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF DENTAL PLANS, WHO
IS A SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
THURMOND SUMMARIZED IT WELL.
IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE BILL. IT
JUST EXTENDS THE DEADLINE,
IMPLEMENTATION DATE FOR US TO
IMPLEMENT THESE APIS, WHICH ARE
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED. THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DID NOT
MANDATE THAT WE DO IT, BUT
CALIFORNIA IS, AND WE NEED SOME
TIME TO DO THAT. WE APPRECIATE
THE HELP. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT NAME, AFFILIATION,
POSITION ON THE MEASURE ONLY
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON. TIM
VALDERRAMA WITH THE WHITMAN
GROUP ON BEHALF OF DENTAQUEST ON
LIFE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? NAME, AFFILIATION,
POSITION ON THE MEASURE. OH, YOU
MAY BE YOUR LEAD WITNESS. PLEASE
COME DOWN. NO, ACTUALLY, I'M
VERY HAPPY TO BE HERE. NOT
OPPOSITION ANYMORE. VANESSA
KAHINA, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK WITH THE AMENDMENT
SUGGESTING THE ANALYSIS AND THE
PATIENTS AND THE WORK OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR, WE CAN
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT. NEXT, PLEASE. CHRISTINE
SMITH, HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
WITH ADOPTION OF COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, WE REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON AMENDS. THANK YOU
TO NEXT, PLEASE, AARON TAYLOR
WITH POLITICAL SOLUTIONS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION. ALSO LOOK FORWARD
TO REVIEWING THE AMENDS AND
ANTICIPATE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. OKAY SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE,
BRING THE MATTER BACK TO THE
DESK. MY COLLEAGUES, COLLEAGUES,
ANY QUESTIONS, COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS? OKAY, I NEED A WHO DID
THAT? SENATOR LIMON MOTION BY
SENATOR LIMÓN. THE MOTION, BY
THE WAY, IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YOU MAY CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. OKAY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH A ROTH AYE. WHEN I WHEN I
GLASER GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ. AYE.
GROVE. GROVE. AYE HURTADO. AYE.
HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. LIMÓN.
AYE. MENGIBAR. RUBIO AYE. RUBIO.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO. WILL
HOLD THE ROLE. OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. SENATORS
OKAY. NEXT ITEM IS AS SOME
MEMBER HAYNIE, ITEM NUMBER 16,
TÍNH AB 2365 PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, AB 2365 WILL PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS BY
ESTABLISHING HEALTH AND SAFETY
REGULATIONS FOR KRATOM PRODUCTS
SOLD IN THE STATE. KRATOM IS A
TREE IN THE COFFEE FAMILY NATIVE
TO SOUTHEAST ASIA AND IN LOW
DOSES, KRATOM PRODUCES CAN
PRODUCE A BENEFICIAL STIMULANT
EFFECT LIKE INCREASED ENERGY,
ALERTNESS, CONCENTRATION ON
PHYSICAL ENERGY, AND
PRODUCTIVITY. BUT IN HIGH DOSES,
KRATOM CAUSES A SEDATIVE EFFECT
AND OTHER NEGATIVE SYMPTOMS LIKE
NAUSEA, INCREASED HEART RATE,
INSOMNIA, AND SOME PSYCHOTIC
SYMPTOMS LIKE HALLUCINATIONS AND
CONFUSION. ADDITIONALLY,
CONSISTENT KRATOM USE CAN LEAD
TO DEPENDENCY. HOWEVER, SOME
PEOPLE CONSUME KRATOM AS A LESS
DANGEROUS REPLACEMENT FOR
OPIOIDS AND OPIOID USE DISORDER.
IN THE ABSENCE OF FEDERAL
ACTION, MANY STATES ACTUALLY
MOST STATES HAVE DECIDED TO
REGULATE KRATOM SO THAT ONLY
SAFE AND UNADULTERATED PRODUCTS
ARE BEING SOLD TO CONSUMERS.
HOWEVER NEARLY 25% OF ALL KRATOM
SALES ARE IN THE UNITED STATES
ARE IN CALIFORNIA, AND THE
INCREASE IN DEMAND OF KRATOM
PRODUCT AND THE LACK OF
REGULATIONS CAN LEAD SOME
MANUFACTURERS TO IRRESPONSIBLY
CREATE STRONGER AND MORE POTENT
KRATOM CONCENTRATES TO PUT INTO
THEIR PRODUCTS TO PREVENT
UNADULTERATED, HIGH POTENCY
PRODUCTS FROM HURTING CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. AS AB 2365 WILL ENACT
ROBUST REGULATIONS FOR KRATOM
PRODUCTS THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH, IT
WILL ENSURE MANUFACTURERS ARE
ONLY PRODUCING SAFE KRATOM
PRODUCTS, AND THE CONSUMER IS
ABLE TO MAINTAIN ACCESS TO THE
BENEFITS OF THEM. I AM ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS, WHICH I REALLY
WANT TO APPRECIATE. THE
COMMITTEE FOR THOSE WHICH I
THINK STRENGTHEN THE BILL, AND
I'M GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK THAT
HAS BEEN DONE AND ALSO BE
WORKING WITH CDPH TO REFINE THE
BILL AND LOOK FORWARD TO
RECEIVING THEIR FEEDBACK ON THE
TECHNICAL PIECES. HERE TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS DAVID BREGAR, A
PARENT AND ADVOCATE FOR SAFE,
CREATE AND REGULATIONS, AND
DOCTOR AARON BERTHOLD, AN EXPERT
ON KRATOM. WELCOME. PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD BEFORE YOU SPEAK AND
PROCEED WHEN READY. MY NAME IS
DAVID BRAGER. I'D LIKE TO THANK
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FOR GIVING
ME TIME TODAY, TRUTH BE TOLD,
I'D RATHER NOT BE HERE TODAY.
I'M HERE TO TELL A STORY. MY SON
DAN, HE WAS 33 YEARS OLD WHEN HE
DIED OF AN OVERDOSE OF KRATOM.
AND IT WAS ONE OF THESE PRODUCTS
THAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT, WHICH
IS THESE HYPER CONCENTRATED
PRODUCTS THAT ARE EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS. AND THEY'RE GETTING
MORE DANGEROUS BY THE DAY. HE
LEFT BEHIND HIS MOTHER, MYSELF
AND HIS BROTHER, HIS BROTHER,
TWO YEARS YOUNGER THAN HIM, NOT
ONLY LOST HIS BROTHER, BUT HIS
BEST FRIEND. LOSING A CHILD IS A
NIGHTMARE THAT YOU WAKE UP WITH
EVERY DAY AND YOU GO TO BED WITH
EVERY NIGHT. YOUR PARENTS LOSING
A CHILD HAVE AN 80% DIVORCE RATE
. LUCKILY, WE'RE GETTING THROUGH
IT SO FAR, BUT THE FUTURE IS,
YOU KNOW, IT IS CHANGED FOREVER.
I'M NOT LOOKING FOR PITY OR
SYMPATHY TODAY. I'M LOOKING FOR
YOU TO PASS THESE REGULATIONS
AND SAY AYE TO THESE
REGULATIONS. TWO PLUS YEARS
AFTER DAN DIED THROUGH A CHANCE
MEETING WITH A WASHINGTON POST
WRITER, HE WROTE AN ARTICLE ON
KRATOM AND TOLD MY SON'S STORY.
THAT GOT ME MOTIVATED TO GET OUT
AND TRY AND DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THE PROLIFERATION OF KRATOM. I
HAD HIGH AND MIGHTY IDEAS OF,
BANNING THE PRODUCT IN MY HOME
STATE OF NEW HAMPSHIRE QUICKLY
HIT A BRICK WALL AND A LOT OF
FRUSTRATION THROUGH ANOTHER,
COINCIDENCE, I MET UP WITH THE,
GLOBAL KRATOM COALITION THÀNH,
AND REALIZED WE HAD VERY SIMILAR
GOALS AND I REALIZED THAT
SIGNIFICANT REGULATIONS COULD
HAVE A MUCH QUICKER RESULT AND
SAVE LIVES. THROUGH MY EARLY
EFFORTS, I ALSO LEARNED OF THE
AMERICAN KRATOM ASSOCIATION, WHO
I JUST FOUND OUT THAT THEY ARE
OPPOSING THIS BILL, WHICH I FIND
INCREDIBLY HYPOCRITICAL, AS IN
THEIR PODCAST INTERVIEWS AND
THEIR WEBSITE, THEY SPEAK OF
NOTHING BUT INCREASED
REGULATIONS FOR THE PRODUCT. BUT
AS DEATHS CONTINUE TO INCREASE
AND THEY MOSTLY DENY THE DEATHS
THAT ARE ACTUALLY TAKING PLACE,
THE REGULATIONS THAT THEY'RE
PUSHING HAVE NO TEETH
WHATSOEVER. THESE REGULATIONS DO
AND WILL GO A LONG WAY. ALSO,
PLEASE DON'T LOOK TO THE FDA.
THEY'RE SPREAD PAPER THIN.
PEOPLE CONTINUE TO DIE. NOW IS
THE TIME TO ACT AND SAVE LIVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
LOVE YOU DAN, FOREVER AND ALWAYS
. SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS AND THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US. YES, MA'AM.
YES. HELLO, I'M DOCTOR AARON
ZUBIATE, KERATERM RESEARCHER,
EDUCATOR, ADVOCATE. I SPENT FIVE
YEARS STUDYING KRATOM AND
CANNABIS INTERACTIONS IN
PRECLINICAL MODELS OF PAIN AND
ADDICTION AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
FLORIDA. TO EARN MY PHD. AND
SINCE THEN, I'VE CONTINUED TO
RESEARCH AND ADVOCATE FOR THE
SAFE AND APPROPRIATE USE OF
KRATOM. KRATOM IS A FASCINATING
PLANT. IT CAN BOTH STIMULATE AND
SEDATE. I LOVE COMPLEXITY, SO I
WAS REALLY DRAWN TO RESEARCH TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT IT IS
THAT CAUSES THESE DICHOTOMOUS
EFFECTS. THE CAUSE LIES IN THE
ACTIVE CONSTITUENTS. THEY'RE
CALLED ALKALOIDS, AND THEY HIT
MULTIPLE RECEPTOR SUBTYPES
WITHIN THE HUMAN BODY. SINCE I
BEGAN STUDYING KRATOM BACK IN
2016, CONSUMPTION IN THE UNITED
STATES HAS RAPIDLY INCREASED, OR
ABOUT 2 MILLION ESTIMATED USERS.
BACK THEN, OVER 20 MILLION
ESTIMATED USERS NOW, INDIVIDUALS
USE IT TO SELF-TREAT MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS, SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS TO MANAGE PAIN AND
THIS INCREASE IN THE RISE OF USE
HAS ALSO CAUSED THE MARKETPLACE
TO EVOLVE AND EXPLODE WITH
DIFFERENT PRODUCT FORMATS,
DIFFERENT PRODUCT PRODUCT
STRENGTHS. AND WE'RE RELYING ON
SAFETY DATA FROM, FROM, YOU
KNOW, CENTURIES OF TRADITIONAL
USE IN SOUTHEAST ASIA, BUT
REALLY NO USE IN THE UNITED
STATES. MIRRORS TRADITIONAL USE.
SO, YOU KNOW, TRADITIONALLY THEY
TAKE THE FRESH LEAVES OFF THE
TREE, BREW THEM FOR A FEW HOURS
INTO A TEA, AND THAT'S WHAT THEY
CONSUME. INSTEAD, WE HAVE DRIED
LEAF POWDERS THAT ARE
POST-PROCESSED MANUFACTURED IN
DIFFERENT WAYS. AND RESEARCH ON
THE LONG TERM USE OF THESE. I'D
CALL THEM WESTERN OR UNITED
STATES KRATOM PRODUCTS IS REALLY
SPARSE, SO IN THE ABSENCE OF
THAT DATA, WE DEFINITELY NEED
REGULATIONS WHILE WE BUILD THOSE
SAFETY PROFILES FOR THOSE TYPES
OF PRODUCTS, AT THE MOST RECENT
MEETING OF KRATOM RESEARCHERS,
WE HAD ONE BACK IN FEBRUARY, OUR
SOUTHEAST ASIAN COUNTERPARTS ARE
VERY CLEAR, LESS KRATOM IS MORE,
AND I THINK WE DO REALLY, REALLY
WELL TO HEED THEIR, CAUTIONS AS
THERE ARE POTENTIAL NEGATIVE
SIDE EFFECTS WITH IRRESPONSIBLE
CONSUMPTION OF KRATOM,
REGULATIONS ARE NECESSARY TO
PROTECT BOTH ACCESS AND PUBLIC
HEALTH. ACCESS MUST BE
MAINTAINED FOR THOSE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO ARE GETTING
POSITIVE BENEFITS FROM KRATOM.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IS THREATENED, IF THESE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE AVAILABLE ARE
AVAILABLE WITH NO NO SAFETY
INFORMATION, NO REGULATION,
NOTHING IS STOPPING THEM FROM
GETTING BIGGER, BETTER, STRONGER
. THE KRATOM IS A PLANT. ITS
POTENTIAL TO IMPROVE THE LIVES
OF MANY AMERICANS REALLY DEPENDS
ON THE COOPERATION OF
SCIENTISTS, REGULATORS,
ADVOCATES, INDUSTRY Kò TO REALLY
EDUCATE AND ADVOCATE FOR THAT
APPROPRIATE AND SAFE USE OF
KRATOM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, NAME, AFFILIATION
AND POSITION ON THE MEASURE ONLY
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS. RYAN SHERMAN,
TODAY, REPRESENTING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL, THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION, THE
CALIFORNIA NARCOTIC OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION, THE POLICE OFFICER
ASSOCIATION, ASSOCIATIONS OF
SANTA ANA, RIVERSIDE, CULVER
CITY, POMONA, CORONA, NOVATO,
UPLAND, ARCADIA, BURBANK, LÀ
SCHOOL, POLICE, FULLERTON, PEOA,
MARIETTA, NEWPORT BEACH, PALOS
VERDES, CLAREMONT, PLASSARD,
DEPUTY SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION,
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF SCHOOLS
SAFETY PROFESSIONALS, RIVERSIDE
POLICE CHIEF LARRY GONZALES, SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY SHERIFF
SHANNON DICUS, RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHERIFF CHAD BIANCO, ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. AND I'LL
JUST CONCUR WITH THE COMMENTS.
THE OTHER WITNESSES, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ATTENDING TODAY,
GENTLEMEN. CHAIR MURPHY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT,
PLEASE. HI. THANK YOU. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, RYAN PERRINE, ON
BEHALF OF MIT, 45, PART OF THE
GLOBAL KRATOM COALITION AND
PROUD SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. NEXT, PLEASE. DAVID
QUINTANA WITH A GLOBAL KRATOM
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US, MA'AM. DIONNE EVANS,
I'M A TERMINAL PATIENT WHO'S
USED KRATOM FOR EIGHT YEARS NOW.
I'M AN ADVOCATE AND IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB 2365. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US. NEXT,
PLEASE. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
JULIA SMITH. I'VE BEEN A
CONSUMER FOR OVER SIX YEARS NOW
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. YES, SIR.
VICTOR MORFIN I'M A CONSUMER AND
AFTER MY CYCLING ACCIDENT, I
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
YES, MA'AM. HI. MY NAME IS
MARCEL MORFIN AND I HAVE BEEN A
CONSUMER FOR ABOUT SEVEN YEARS.
I'M ALSO AN ADVOCATE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANKS FOR JOINING US. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? LET'S TURN
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
MR. CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS. RAND
MARTIN, ON BEHALF OF THE
HOLISTIC ALTERNATIVE RECOVERY
TRUST. QUITE A MOUTHFUL. IT'S A
NEW ORGANIZATION THAT WAS
CREATED NATIONALLY OF ENTITIES
AND BUSINESSES THAT ARE
INTERESTED IN PROMOTING PLANT
BASED SOLUTIONS TO OPIOID
ADDICTION, KRATOM, ONE OF THE
THINGS HAS NOT BEEN TALKED ABOUT
TODAY IS THAT KRATOM IS ACTUALLY
A VERY EFFECTIVE, AND ITS
ALKALOID CONSTITUENTS. IT VERY
EFFECTIVE IN RELIEVING THE
SYMPTOMS AND THE EFFECTS OF
OPIOID ADDICTION AND SOMETIMES
BETTER THAN PHARMACEUTICAL,
OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO,
TO PATIENTS. I WANT TO SAY FROM
THE OUTSET THAT OUR ORGANIZATION
THINKS MOST OF THIS BILL IS
REALLY GOOD. AND THESE
REGULATORY APPROACHES THAT MR.
HAYNES IS TAKING ARE REALLY
GOING TO BE EFFECTIVE, IN
CALIFORNIA, AGE GATING IS VERY
IMPORTANT. GETTING SOME OF THE
HEAVY METALS AND SOLVENTS OUT OF
THE PRODUCT IS VERY IMPORTANT,
GETTING SOME OF THE OTHER
CONSTITUENTS OUT OF OUT OF THE
PRODUCT IS VERY IMPORTANT. THE
ONE THING THAT CAUSES US CONCERN
AND WHY WE HAVEN'T OPPOSED,
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION, IS THAT
THE ONE ELEMENT THAT DOES THE
MOST BENEFIT BIT FOR GETTING
PEOPLE OFF OF OPIOIDS IS HYDROXY
MITRAGYNINE. THAT IS ONE OF THE
ALKALOIDS IN KRATOM, ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL SAYS
THAT THERE SHALL BE NO MORE THAN
1% OF 708, WHICH IS THE
SHORTHAND FOR THAT VERY LONG
NAME, THAT NO MORE THAN 1, OUR
MEMBERS WHO MANY OF WHOM ARE
MANUFACTURERS, MANY OF THEM WHO
KNOW WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
PATIENTS WHO ARE USING KRATOM
FOR THESE PURPOSES, ARE VERY
CONCERNED THAT AT THAT LOW OF A
LEVEL, THAT THEY WILL NO LONGER
HAVE THE EFFICACIOUS BENEFITS OF
KRATOM FOR THAT POPULATION. WE
HAVE SUGGESTED TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THAT A SLIGHTLY HIGHER,
LEVEL WOULD BE APPROPRIATE FOR
THIS. WE HAVE ASKED FOR A 2% BY
DRY WEIGHT INSTEAD OF A 1%
THAT'S CURRENTLY IN THE BILL, WE
THINK THAT IS STILL KEEPS THE
BILL FROM BEING ADULTERATED, BUT
AT THE SAME TIME ENSURES THAT
THE KRATOM PRODUCT IS AVAILABLE
TO PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE
BENEFITS THAT THIS DOCTOR NOTED
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO MANY
CALIFORNIANS, THE BOTTOM LINE
HERE IS THAT IN CREATING A BRAND
NEW REGULATORY STRUCTURE ON A
PRODUCT THAT MOST OF US HAD
NEVER HEARD OF BEFORE, MR. HANEY
INTRODUCED THIS BILL WITHOUT THE
SCIENTIFIC BACKGROUND NECESSARY
TO COME TO THE RIGHT NUMBER,
RELATIVE TO 708. WE HAVE TO BE
VERY CAREFUL ABOUT GOING DOWN
THAT PATH, BECAUSE WE DO RUN THE
RISK THAT WHEN THIS BILL BECOMES
LAW, AND WE DO HOPE THAT IN A
GOOD WAY, IT BECOMES LAW, THAT
WHEN IT BECOMES LAW THAT WE'RE
NOT SHUTTING DOWN THIS OPTION.
FOR MANY OF THE CONSUMERS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO FIND GREAT
BENEFIT FROM THIS, FROM THIS
PRODUCT. SO WE ENCOURAGE THE
AUTHOR, WE ENCOURAGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO FIND A NUMBER THAT
WORKS SO THAT WE BALANCE OUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE OF THE PRODUCT
WITH KEEPING THE INDUSTRY, THE
PROVIDERS OF THIS PRODUCT ALIVE
AND SERVING CALIFORNIANS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE, LET'S BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE DAIS. AND MY
COLLEAGUES. ANY COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS, CONCERNS? I SEE
SENATOR RUBIO WITH HER HAND UP,
SENATOR. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, I
HAVE A LOT OF THOUGHTS ON THIS
ISSUE. WELL, FIRST OF ALL, THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD. I
MEAN, I CONSIDER MYSELF AN
EDUCATED INDIVIDUAL. AND YET
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WASN'T ON
MY RADAR AS AN EDUCATOR, A
TEACHER FOR 20 YEARS. YOU KNOW,
YOU HEAR THE VAPING, YOU HEAR
EVEN FENTANYL HAS BEEN, YOU
KNOW, QUITE PUBLICIZED. BUT THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT'S QUITE NEW TO
ME. SO THANK YOU FOR AT LEAST
EDUCATING US ON THE TOPIC, AND,
AND JUST LIKE ANYTHING ELSE, IF
WE DON'T HAVE REGULATION, IT
TENDS TO GET OUT OF CONTROL.
WE'VE SEEN THAT WITH THE
FENTANYL. AND THEN KIDS START
GETTING CREATIVE AND MIXING
THINGS. AND SO I JUST WANT TO
FOR CLARIFICATION PURPOSES. SO
RIGHT NOW THERE'S NO AGE LIMIT
AND ANYBODY COULD PURCHASE IT.
SO WHAT YOUR BILL IS INTENDING
TO DO IS CAP IT AT, NO ONE UNDER
THE AGE OF 21, CORRECT? YES.
RIGHT NOW THERE THERE ARE NO AGE
LIMITS TO BUY KRATOM IN
CALIFORNIA. IN MOST OTHER STATES
THERE ARE. I THINK THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT ELEMENT OF THIS BILL,
WHICH I WHOLEHEARTEDLY, YOU
KNOW, SUPPORT. BUT THEN I ALSO
HEARD YOUR NUMBERS. I'M SORRY, I
CAN'T REMEMBER. THE RESEARCHER,
YOU KNOW, THE NUMBER IS
STAGGERING. 20 MILLION USERS.
LIKE I SAID, I'VE NEVER HEARD OF
THIS. SO TO ME IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GONE UNDER THE RADAR. AND
IN ANY CASE, WHEN SOMETHING YOU
KNOW, STARTS AGAIN GETTING OUT
OF HAND OR KIDS GETTING CREATIVE
AND OVER USING IT AND, YOU KNOW,
LIKE YOUR SON AND I'M SORRY, I
BELIEVE IT'S DAN. MY
CONDOLENCES, THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT'S
UNREGULATED. CORRECT. AND IT'S
HAPPENING WITH FENTANYL AND
OTHER THINGS. AND SO I THINK
CREATING THIS REGULATORY
STRUCTURE IS IMPORTANT NOT ONLY
TO PREVENT, YOU KNOW, THESE
KINDS OF, OF ABUSES AND USES,
BUT, YOU KNOW, THE WAY THINGS
ARE MANUFACTURED, THE WAY THINGS
ARE TESTED, IT'S IMPORTANT. I
JUST DON'T SEE WHY ANYONE WOULD
NOT BE IN FAVOR OF MAKING SURE
THAT PRODUCTS ARE SAFE. NOW, I
DO HEAR YOUR CONCERN, OAN. I'M
SORRY. THE OPPOSITION WHO,
PERHAPS MIGHT NOT BE IN
AGREEMENT OVER THE 1, BUT YOU
SAID SOMETHING THAT IT'S NOT
BASED ON SCIENTIFIC INFORMATION,
SO I'M GOING TO TURN IT OVER TO
THE AUTHOR OR THOSE THAT ARE AT
THE TABLE. CAN YOU SHARE THAT 1%
CAME FROM. YEAH. SO THE 1% IS,
FROM, YOU KNOW, THE BEST
RESEARCH AND SCIENCE THAT WE
HAVE OF WHERE TO DRAW THE LINE
IN TERMS OF, THE, THE AMOUNT
IT'S ALSO REFLECTIVE OF WHAT
MOST OTHER STATES ARE DOING,
MOST OF THE OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE SET A LIMIT OR ARE
CONSIDERING A LIMIT ARE SETTING
IT AT 1, SO THIS IS WHERE THE
BEST SCIENCE AND RESEARCH IS
POINTING US TO. NOW WE CERTAINLY
COULD, IF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH, PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS INPUT OR OTHER
THOUGHTS ON THIS, WE WOULD BE
OPEN TO THAT. BUT RIGHT NOW,
THAT'S WHERE THE BEST SCIENCE
IS. I DON'T KNOW IF OTHER FOLKS
WANT TO IF ANY OF THE WITNESSES
THROUGH THE CHAIR WANT TO
RESPOND FOR IT. YES, PLEASE.
YEAH, I'D LIKE TO CHIME IN,
FIRST I'D LIKE TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THEY'RE NOT ASKING FOR A CHANGE
FROM 1 TO 2% RIGHT NOW IN THE
BILL, IT'S WRITTEN AS 1% OF THE
ALKALOID FRACTION. SO IT'S 1% OF
A FRACTION OF THE PRODUCT. SO
IT'S ACTUALLY A BIG CHANGE. IT
COULD BE 1000 TO 10,000% CHANGE
THEY'RE ASKING FOR. SO IT'S NOT
A SMALL CHANGE. AND WE PUT A
LIMIT ON SEVEN
HYDROXYMITRAGYNINE BECAUSE WE
KNOW IT IS A STRONGER MU OPIOID
RECEPTOR AGONIST. AND IT SHOULD
NOT BE FOUND IN THE NATIVE PLANT
MATERIAL IN ANY SORT OF
ABUNDANCE, IN ANY SORT OF
QUANTITY. WE SEE IT IN PLANT
MATERIAL. IT'S NOT PRODUCED BY
THE PLANT. THERE'S NO ENZYMES IN
THE PLANT THAT MAKE IT. IT'S A
DEGRADATION OF THE DRYING
PROCESS. AND YOU USUALLY GET
LIKE 0.05% BY WEIGHT, IF THAT,
IF THERE'S ANYTHING EVEN
DETECTABLE. SO BECAUSE WE KNOW,
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE LIMIT IS
FOR IT YET, BUT BECAUSE WE KNOW
IT SHOULDN'T BE THERE IN NATURE
AND BECAUSE WE KNOW IT HAS
POTENTIAL, THESE BILLS ARE BEING
WRITTEN TO MAKE SURE THAT NO
ONE'S KNOWS THIS COMPOUND COULD
BE A LITTLE STRONGER, SO THEY'RE
JUST SPIKING IT. I THINK BACK IN
2016 OR 2018 EARLY, EARLY ON.
AND WE DON'T KNOW IF IT WAS
INTENTIONAL BECAUSE AT THAT TIME
WE DON'T KNOW THAT THEY KNEW,
BUT THERE WERE PRODUCTS ON THE
MARKET, I THINK LIKE DECKER'S
STUDY THAT THEY HAD LIKE THREE,
4 OR 5% OF SEVEN HYDROXY, WHICH
WE KNEW MEANT THEY WERE
ADULTERATED. SO WE CONSIDER
PRODUCTS LIKE THAT IN THE
INDUSTRY. IF THEY HAVE MORE THAN
1. SEVEN HYDROXYMITRAGYNINE THAT
THEY'RE ADULTERATED. THANK YOU.
WELL, I HAVE TO ADMIT, SHE LOST
ME SOMEWHERE ALONG THE LINE.
DOCTOR RESEARCHER. YES, BUT
THAT'S THE POINT. I JUST WANT TO
MAKE CLEAR IT WAS VERY
INFORMATIONAL. I WAS JUST
KIDDING. YES SOME TERMINOLOGY IS
DIFFICULT TO UNDERSTAND, BUT.
BUT I GET YOUR POINT. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE. BECAUSE WHEN
I HEARD IT, I THOUGHT THERE
WASN'T ANY SCIENCE BEHIND IT OR.
BUT YOU KNOW, WHAT I'M HEARING
IS THERE'S RESEARCH, THERE'S
SCIENCE, AND YOU'RE BASICALLY
COPYING THIS BASED ON OTHER
RESEARCH INFORMATION AND OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED THIS CORRECT. SO I
WON'T BELABOR THE POINT. I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE WAS
SOME SOME SCIENCE AND
INFORMATION BEHIND IT. SO I'LL
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU. AND I WILL ADD AS A
COAUTHOR BECAUSE ANYTHING AGAIN,
THAT WE CAN REGULATE AND MAKE
SURE IT'S SAFE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES IS IMPORTANT. SO
THANK YOU. DEFINITELY. AND IT'S
ALSO I JUST THROUGH THE CHAIR,
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE
REGULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA, WE'RE
SEEING A LOT MORE ATTEMPTS TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT FACT
HERE. SO YOU'RE SEEING ENTIRE
STORES OPENING THAT ARE SELLING
SOME OF THIS MORE POTENT
SYNTHETIC TYPE. AND SO THIS IS
ALSO ABOUT PREVENTION, BECAUSE
IF WE DON'T DO THESE
REGULATIONS, WE'RE GOING TO SEE
YOU'RE IF YOU DON'T YOU HAVEN'T
HEARD ABOUT IT NOW. BUT PROBABLY
NEXT YEAR YOU WOULD HAVE. AND WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THERE ARE
REGULATIONS IN PLACE TO PREVENT
SOME OF THE MORE HARMFUL FORMS.
SO I JUST WANT TO DO YOU HAVE A
RESPONSE TO THE SENATOR? YEAH,
LET ME TRY. AND I'M NOT A
SCIENTIST. I'M NOT A RESEARCHER.
I'M JUST A LOBBYIST, WHICH IS A
GOOD THING TOO. BUT I JUST WANT
TO MAKE A COUPLE OF POINTS. ONE
IS, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO MR.
HANEY, THE SCIENCE IS VERY
INCONCLUSIVE ON THIS. AT THIS
POINT. AND PICKING A NUMBER,
LIKE 1, BECAUSE SOME RESEARCH
MIGHT SUGGEST THAT 1% IS A GOOD
NUMBER. IGNORES OTHER RESEARCH
THAT SAYS THAT OTHER NUMBERS MAY
BE GOOD TO. THE IMPORTANT THING
IS TO MAKE MAKING SURE THAT THE
NUMBER IS LOW ENOUGH THAT IT'S
NOT ADULTERATED. THE OTHER POINT
I WANTED TO CLARIFY IS THAT
THERE ARE SOME OTHER STATES THAT
HAVE DONE SOME LEGISLATION, SOME
STATUTE RELATIVE TO THIS. FOUR
OF THEM HAVE ACTUALLY 2, A
COUPLE OF THEM DO HAVE 1, BUT IT
IS NOT THE NORM. MANY OF THEM
HAVE NO PERCENTAGE OF 700 IN
THEIR LAW, BUT THEY HAVE OTHER
THINGS TO TRY AND CONSTRAIN HOW
THAT PRODUCT IS ADULTERATED.
RHODE ISLAND, FOR EXAMPLE, JUST
LAST WEEK THEY HAD A BILL. THEY
HAVE A BILL THAT HAD 1% IN IT.
THE LEGISLATURE TOOK THAT 1% OUT
AND PUT IN SOME OTHER STUFF THAT
CONSTRAINED THE USE OF
ADULTERATION, BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT THINK THAT THERE WAS A
NUMBER THAT WAS APPROPRIATE AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE OF THE
INCONCLUSIVE, INCONCLUSIVE VIÆT
OF CURRENT RESEARCH. THANK YOU.
WELL, ISN'T ONE ISN'T SOME OF
THE PROBLEM THAT DRY WEIGHT IS
REALLY NOT AN INDICATOR OF WHAT
THE FINAL PRODUCT LOOKS LIKE?
YOU SAID 2% DRY WEIGHT, RIGHT?
RIGHT, RIGHT. ISN'T ISN'T THE
REAL ISSUE THAT DRY WEIGHT ISN'T
A REAL INDICATION OF WHAT THE
FINAL PRODUCT THAT THE USER GETS
LOOKS LIKE. I THINK THE ANSWER
TO THAT IS IF WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT FINAL PRODUCT, THEN WE
NEED TO BE LOOKING AT FINAL
PRODUCT AND WHAT THE FINAL
PRODUCT HAS RELATIVE TO 700 H,
AND THAT'S, YOU KNOW, DRY
WEIGHT, DRY WEIGHT AS, AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, AGAIN, I'M NO, NO
EXPERT, BUT DRY WEIGHT IS WHAT
IS IN THE PRODUCT AFTER YOU TAKE
ALL THE MOISTURE OUT OF IT, AND
SO IT'S NOT NECESSARILY IT MAY
BE HIGHER THAN 2, BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT AS HIGH AS SOME OF
THE ADULTERATED PRODUCT THAT
WE'VE BEEN SEEING ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. AND IT'S AND IT'S NOT
AN INDICATOR OF WHAT THE FINAL
PRODUCT IS THAT SOMEONE MIGHT
CONSUME. RIGHT I, I THINK THAT
IT IS IT IS A QUESTION ABOUT
WHAT THE WHAT THE WHAT THE
KRATOM THAT GOES INTO THE
PRODUCT LOOKS LIKE, AS OPPOSED
TO WHAT COMES OUT AT THE
PRODUCT. SAME ISSUE WE'VE HAD
WITH HEMP, AS THE CHAIR KNOWS,
SAME ISSUE WE'VE HAD WITH
CANNABIS RELATIVE TO WHAT DOES
IT LOOK LIKE GOING IN, WHAT DOES
IT LOOK LIKE COMING OUT? AND WE
KNOW WITH WITH HEMP THAT THE DRY
WEIGHT IS NOT AN INDICATOR OF
WHAT COMES OUT ON THE OTHER END.
RIGHT? ABSOLUTELY. WE TOTALLY
AGREE WITH YOU ON THAT. AND
THAT'S AND THAT MAYBE THAT'S
WHAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT IS,
IS WHAT COMES OUT AT THE OTHER
END IN TERMS OF ADULTERATION.
OKAY. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, CONCERNS? SENATOR
WIENER, THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
THANK YOU, THE AUTHOR, FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I SUPPORT
THE BILL, AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
BE ADDED AS A COAUTHOR. I DO
THINK IT'S, THIS ISSUE IS AN
INTERESTING ONE BECAUSE IT ALSO
REMINDS US OF THE COMPLETE CHAOS
AND IRRATIONALITY OF HOW WE
TREAT SUBSTANCES THAT CAN HELP
PEOPLE, WE HAVE THIS SUBSTANCE
WHICH IS NOT REGULATED AT ALL.
WE HAVE PSYCHEDELICS, WHICH ALSO
CAN HELP PEOPLE STOP USING
OPIOIDS, WHICH ARE BLANKET
ILLEGAL DESPITE OUR BEST EFFORTS
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS, WE
HAVE SOME PRODUCTS THAT ARE
MAYBE IN SOME FORM HAVE BEEN
NARROWLY APPROVED BY THE FDA,
BUT IN OTHER FORMS HAVEN'T AND
CAN ONLY BE USED IN CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND THEN WE HAVE
SOME SUBSTANCE. SO IT'S JUST,
IT'S A MESS AND IT ENDS UP
HARMING PEOPLE WHO NEED HELP,
AND SO I THINK THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT APPROACH TO SAY, LET'S
TAKE THIS AND PUT SOME BASIC
CONSTRAINTS AROUND IT. AND
PEOPLE CAN ARGUE ABOUT WHAT THE
RIGHT, YOU KNOW, FORM OF IT
SHOULD BE. BUT TO ME, THE KEY
STEP IS, IS ACTUALLY BRINGING IT
INTO THE FULL SUNLIGHT AND
GETTING SOME HEALTH AND SAFETY,
GUARDRAILS AROUND IT. AND SO I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU. AND I'M SO SORRY. OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL, SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS OR CONCERNS,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE TO THE EXTENT THAT YOU
HAVEN'T? YES. THANK YOU. AND OF
COURSE, I WOULD LOVE FOR FOLKS
TO BE ADDED AS A COAUTHOR. AND
THANKS SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND
TO YOUR STAFF, I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS AND WE
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
PERCENTAGES AND ENGAGE WITH CDPH
AROUND THAT. AND, AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. OKAY. THE MOTION IS BY
SENATOR RUBIO. IT'S TO DO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH A ROTH I WHEN I WHEN I
GLASER GONZALES. GROVE. GROVE I
HURTADO HURTADO I LIMÓN MENGIBAR
RUBIO. RUBIO I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WIENER WIENER I. CURRENT
VOTES SIX ZERO WILL HOLD THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU ALL FOR JOINING US.
THANK YOU SIR. TAKE CARE. OUR
FINAL ITEM, IS ITEM NUMBER 21 AB
3221. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
AND IT'S DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE REVIEW OF RECORDS.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY. YO
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, AND THANKS TO PAST
EFFORTS BY THE STATE, CALIFORNIA
LEADS THE NATION IN ITS PATIENT
PROTECTION LAWS. AB 3221 WILL
MAKE COMMON SENSE UPDATES TO THE
KNOX KING ACT IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTH CARE'S ABILITY TO
ENFORCE THESE LAWS AND REMOVE
PROCEDURAL HURDLES TO EFFICIENT
AND EFFECTIVE FORCE ENFORCEMENT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW, DMHC CAN
INSPECT HEALTH PLAN RECORDS, BUT
THE LAW DOES NOT PROVIDE FOR
THOSE RECORDS TO BE FURNISHED
ELECTRONICALLY. AB 3221
STIPULATES THAT HEALTH PLANS
MUST FURNISH RECORDS TO DMHC AND
A DIGITALLY SEARCHABLE FORMAT
WHEN POSSIBLE. THIS SIMPLE
CHANGE WILL REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
TIME AND EFFORT THAT DEPARTMENT
STAFF SPEND REVIEWING RECORDS
AND LOCATING RELEVANT
INFORMATION WHEN CONDUCTING
SURVEYS AND INVESTIGATIONS.
FURTHERMORE, THE BILL ALSO
EMPOWERS DMHC DIRECTOR TO
PENALIZE PLANS IF THEY FAIL TO
RESPOND TO RECORDS REQUESTS
FULLY OR IN A TIMELY MANNER. THE
AB 3221 WILL ALSO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR THE DEPARTMENT TO SEEK
JUDICIAL RELIEF ON A CONSUMER'S
BEHALF BY ALLOWING THE
DEPARTMENT TO DO SO THROUGH AN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW HEARING,
RATHER THAN THROUGH OVERBURDENED
SUPERIOR COURTS AS IS CURRENTLY
REQUIRED. FINALLY, THIS BILL
PROVIDES CLEAR DIRECTION THAT
WHEN DMHC UNCOVERS HEALTH PLAN
VIOLATIONS DURING THE SURVEY
PROCESS, THEY CAN TAKE
ENFORCEMENT ACTION IMMEDIATELY.
SO WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB 3221 IS HEIDI STRUNK,
PRESIDENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICA OF CALIFORNIA, AND DYLAN
ELLIOTT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS. THANK YOU ALL.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY. THANK
YOU. THERE WE GO. THANK YOU. I'M
HEIDI STRUNK. I AM THE CEO AND
PRESIDENT OF MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICA OF CALIFORNIA. WE'RE A
STATEWIDE PEER RUN ORGANIZATION
THAT HAS BEEN ADVOCATING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS SINCE
1957. THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT TO
THOSE OF US WHO WORK TO REFORM
THE FAILURE FIRST SYSTEM OF CARE
INTO A PROACTIVE SYSTEM, A
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS TIMELY,
APPROPRIATE ACCESS PRIOR TO
REACHING CRISIS. MY TESTIMONY
TODAY IS THREE PRONGED. AS A
LEADER OF AN ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION, AS AN EMPLOYER WHO
PAYS PREMIUMS FOR STAFF ACROSS
THE STATE TO OBTAIN THESE
SERVICES, AND AS A FAMILY MEMBER
WHO HAS HAD A LOVED ONE, DENIED
TIMELY ACCESS TO BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CARE, THIS BILL WOULD
PLAY A ROLE IN ASSURING TIMELY
ACCESS BY CLOSING LOOPHOLES THAT
CONTRIBUTE TOWARD DELAYING CARE.
ONE ASPECT OF THE BILL REQUIRES
PLANS TO PROVIDE ELECTRONIC
SURGICAL RECORDS, BOOKS AND
PAPERS. IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONDUCT TIMELY,
EFFICIENT INVESTIGATIONS, WHICH
COULD LEAD TO MITIGATING
BARRIERS TO TIMELY, APPROPRIATE
CARE, AS WHEN MY FAMILY MEMBER
WAS DENIED CARE FOR EIGHT MONTHS
AFTER FIRST SEEKING OUT
TREATMENT. THIS BILL WOULD ALSO
ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO FIND
PLANS WHEN THEY DON'T RESPOND TO
A REQUEST IN RECORD FOR RECORDS
FULLY OR IN A TIMELY MANNER.
HISTORICALLY WE HAVE SEEN THAT
HEALTH PLANS ARE NOT OFTEN
MOTIVATED BY LAWS ALONE TO
COOPERATE WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS. HISTORY HAS
SHOWN US THAT IT IS OFTEN THE
MECHANISM OF MONETARY PENALTIES
THAT MOTIVATES PLANS TO ADHERE
TO THE LAWS THAT DO NOT FURTHER
DELAY APPROPRIATE CARE. BY
EQUIPPING THE DEPARTMENT WITH AS
MANY TOOLS AS POSSIBLE TO
ENFORCE ONGOING ISSUES OF
TIMELY, APPROPRIATE CARE. OUR
STATE'S MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
COULD BE MORE EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESSED AND MITIGATE
SUFFERING, WHICH IS OFTEN
EXACERBATE BY DELAYED CARE, ALL
OF WHICH I HAVE SEEN AS AN
ADVOCATE AND EMPLOYER AND A
FAMILY MEMBER. MENTAL HEALTH
AMERICA OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB 3221. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM. NEXT. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS DILLON
ELLIOTT, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS, KSAP AND ITS
MEMBERS HAVE BEEN AT THE
FOREFRONT OF ADVANCING
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PARITY
NATIONALLY AND IN CALIFORNIA AND
ARE PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR AB 3221,
WHICH TAKES IMPORTANT STEPS
TOWARDS PARITY IN CALIFORNIA. AS
THE AUTHOR AND MISS STRUNK HAVE
INDICATED, FAR TOO OFTEN,
CONSUMERS, PROVIDERS AND
ADVOCATES REPORT HEALTH PLAN
VIOLATIONS THAT IMPEDE ACCESS TO
CARE IN A TIMELY AND APPROPRIATE
MANNER. AB 3221 SIMPLY EMPOWERS
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE TO TAKE FASTER AND MORE
EFFICIENT ENFORCEMENT ACTION
WHEN MERITED, BY MAKING NEEDED
UPDATES TO PROVISIONS IN THE
KNOX KEENE ACT. FOR THESE
REASONS, KSAP IS PROUD TO BE A
CO-SPONSOR. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT, NAME, AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURE ONLY
PLEASE. THANK YOU. VANESSA KAHIN
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PANETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK HERE IN
SUPPORT NEXT, MIA BRITTINGHAM
WITH GREENBERG TRAURIG ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JENNIFER
ROBLESS WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. JULIE NIELSEN REPRESENTING THE
NATIONAL UNION OF HEALTH CARE
WORKERS, SPONSOR OF THIS BILL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
JOHN DREBINGER WITH THE
STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
THANKS GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. TYLER RINDY, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHOLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MEGAN LOBER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU MA'AM.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE. WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE DAIS. AND MY
COLLEAGUES. COLLEAGUES,
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS, CONCERNS.
MOVE THE BILL. SENATOR. MOVE.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR GROVE
SEEING NO OTHERS. SOME MEMBER.
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. IMPROVING HEALTH PLAN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE LAW WILL NOT
ONLY IMPROVE HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
BENEFIT CONSUMERS FINANCIALLY,
BUT WILL ALSO SAVE MONEY BY
REDUCING THE TIME AND MONEY
NEEDED TO CONDUCT ENFORCEMENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROSS A ROTH. AYE. WHEN I WHEN I
GLASER. GLASER I GONZALEZ. GROVE
I GROVE I HURTADO HURTADO I
LIMÓN MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I RUBIO
I RUBIO I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
WIENER. CURRENT VOTES SEVEN ZERO
WILL KEEP THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
PRESENTATION LET'S START BACK AT
THE BEGINNING. ITEM NUMBER. WELL
LET'S DO ITEM NUMBER ONE,
ASSEMBLY BILL 1316, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERWIN EMERGENCY SERVICES,
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. I'LL TAKE A MOTION.
THE MOTION WILL BE TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION SO MOVED BY
SENATOR GROVE? THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROSS. AYE ROTH. I WHEN
I, WHEN I GLASER I GLASER I
GONZALEZ. GROVE I GROVE I
HURTADO HURTADO I LIMÓN MENGIBAR
I MENGIBAR I RUBIO RUBIO I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WIENER.
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO WILL
KEEP THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM TWO AB 1926
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE. REGIONAL
ENTERITIS. THE MOTION WOULD BE
TO PASS AND REFER THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS THERE A
MOTION? MENGIBAR SENATOR
MENGIBAR MOVES THE BILL? PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR ROTH, A
ROTH. AYE. WHEN GLASER A GLASER
I GONZALEZ. GROVE HURTADO.
HURTADO I LIMÓN. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I RUBIO I RUBIO I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER
CURRENT VOTE FIVE ZERO WILL KEEP
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM ITEM NUMBER
THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL 1970 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON MENTAL
HEALTH BLACK MENTAL HEALTH
NAVIGATOR CERTIFICATION. THE
MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS AND
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. IS THERE A
MOTION? MAKE A MOTION, SENATOR
RUBIO, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH, A ROTH. AYE. WHEN GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO. HURTADO.
AYE LIMÓN. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE.
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR. AYE. RUBIO.
AYE RUBIO. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WIENER CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN ZERO WILL KEEP THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
ITEM. ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AB 1975.
BONTA MEDI-CAL. MEDICALLY
SUPPORTIVE FOOD AND NUTRITIONAL
INTERVENTIONS. THE MOTION WOULD
BE TO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION SO MOVED, SENATOR
LIMON, THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH, A ROTH. AYE. WHEN GLASER.
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE
AYE. GROVE. AYE HURTADO.
HURTADO. AYE. LIMÓN HI. LEMON.
AYE. MENGIBAR. MENDEZ AYE.
RUBIO. HI. RUBIO. AYE SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WIENER. CURRENT VOTES
SEVEN ZERO WILL KEEP THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NOW,
LET'S TAKE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTS OF
EIGHT ITEMS. ITEM NUMBER FIVE,
AB 2340. BONTA MEDI-CAL. ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB 2630 BONTA. PUPIL
HEALTH. ITEM NUMBER NINE AB 2043
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERNER, MEDI-CAL.
ITEM NUMBER 15 AB 2343 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ, EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES WITH
AMENDMENTS. ITEM NUMBER 17 AB
2574 ASSEMBLY MEMBER, VALENCIA.
ALCOHOLISM OR DRUG ABUSE
RECOVERY OR TREATMENT PROGRAMS
AND FACILITIES, ITEM NUMBER 18,
AB 2687. REMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE, ITEM NUMBER
19, AB 27 001. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
VÆ VALLAPUDUA, MEDI-CAL AND ITEM
NUMBER 20, AB 2767 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, SANTIAGO. FINANCIAL
SOLVENCY STANDARDS BOARD. THE
MOTION IS TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AND THE FLOOR. IS THERE
A MOTION? MOVE IT. SENATOR
NGUYEN, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH. AYE. ROTH. AYE.
WHEN I WHEN I GLASER. GLASER I.
GONZALEZ. GROVE. GROVE I.
HURTADO. HURTADO. I LIMÓN. I
LIMON. I MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. I.
RUBIO RUBIO. I. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WIENER CURRENT VOTE IS
EIGHT ZERO. WILL KEEP THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2786. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, BONTA CERTIFIED MOBILE
FARMERS MARKETS MOTION WOULD BE
Dð PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. IS THERE A
MOTION? SO MOVED BY SENATOR
DEMONN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH I ROTH I WHEN I WHEN I
GLASER. GLASER I GONZALEZ.
GROVE. GROVE. I HURTADO. HURTADO
Þ I LIMÓN. I LIMÓN. I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. I. RUBIO. RUBIO. I.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO WILL
KEEP THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL
3161. ASSEMBLY MEMBER, BONTA.
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES. THE
MOTION WOULD BE Dð PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. IS THERE A MOTION? SO
MOVED HURTADO BY SENATOR
HURTADO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
ROTH. AYE. ROTH. AYE. WHEN I
WHEN I GLASER. GLASER I.
GONZALEZ. GROVE. GROVE I.
HURTADO. HURTADO. I LIMÓN. I
LIMON. I MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. I
RUBIO. RUBIO, I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WIENER. CURRENT VOTE
EIGHT ZERO. WILL KEEP THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AB
2063 HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. THE
MOTION WOULD BE TO PASS AS
AMENDED. WE REFER THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS. IS THERE A
MOTION? ANY TAKERS? MOTION. SO
MOVED. SENATOR HURTADO, MOVE.
OKAY. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH. AYE. ROTH. AYE
WHEN I WHEN I GLASER, I GLASER I
GONZALEZ. GROVE GROVE I HURTADO.
HURTADO I LIMÓN I LIMON I
MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I RUBIO I
RUBIO I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WIENER. WIENER I CURRENT VOTE
NINE ZERO NEXT. OKAY. SOMEBODY
ELSE I THINK WE'RE EXPECTING
GONZALEZ TO COMMENT. CURRENT
VOTE NINE ZERO WILL HOLD THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 11 A B
2081. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE RECOVERY AND
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. THE MOTION
WILL BE Dð PASS AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
IS THERE A MOTION SENATOR NGUYEN
MOVES? PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH A ROTH. AYE. WHEN I
WHEN I GLASER. GLASER I GONZALEZ
. GROVE. GROVE. I HURTADO.
HURTADO I LIMÓN. I LIMÓN. I
MENGIBAR. I MENGIBAR. I. RUBIO
I. RUBIO. I. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WIENER WIENER. I HEARD VOTE NINE
ZERO. WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER 12 AB 20 105 BY
LOWENTHAL. COVERAGE FOR PANDAS
AND PANS. CURRENT VOTE IS SIX
ZERO. CHAIR VOTING AYE, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. SENATOR GLASER.
GLASER I GROVE. HER YEA. OH, YOU
DID. HURTADO I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WIENER WIENER I. CURRENT
VOTE IS NINE ZERO. CURRENT VOTE
NINE ZERO. AND THAT MATTER. THAT
BILL IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER 13.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2198 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, FLORIDA HEALTH
INFORMATION. CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN ZERO. CHAIR VOTING AYE,
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SEN.
GLASER. GLASER. I MENGIBAR A
MENGIBAR I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WIENER WIENER. I. CURRENT VOTE
IS TEN ZERO AND THAT MATTER IS
OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER 14.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2297 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN HOSPITAL AND
EMERGENCY PHYSICIAN. FAIR
PRICING POLICIES. CURRENT VOTE
IS 4 TO 1. CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SENATOR
GLASER. GROVE. HURTADO HURTADO.
I GROVE. NÓ. MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR
I. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WIENER
FIVE. WIENER I. ARE WE MISSING
ANY? I HAVE NO. THAT ONE CAN BE.
THAT ONE'S DONE. OKAY. THE VOTE
IS 7 TO 2. THAT BILL IS OUT.
NEXT. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
16, AB 2365. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY. PUBLIC HEALTH KRATOM,
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 0. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE. SENATOR GLASER. GLASER I
GONZALEZ. LIMON I LIMON. I
MENGIBAR I MENGIBAR I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. CURRENT VOTE IS NINE
ZERO. WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THE LAST
ITEM. ITEM NUMBER 21 AB 3221.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE. REVIEW OF RECORDS. CURRENT
VOTE IS 7 TO 0. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
SENATOR GONZALEZ LIMÓN A LIMÓN I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WIENER WIENER.
I CURRENT VOTE IS NINE ZERO.
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
LET'S GO BACK THROUGH THE ITEMS,
STARTING WITH, ITEM NUMBER ONE,
AB 1316 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ERWIN. EMERGENCY SERVICES.
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO
0. CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE. SENATOR GONZALEZ LIMÓN
LIMÓN A SMALL WOULD CUEVAS
WIENER WIENER. I CURRENT VOTE
NINE ZERO WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 1926.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONNOLLY. HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE REGIONAL
ENTERITIS. CURRENT VOTE 5 TO 0.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. SENATOR NGUYEN
GONZALEZ GROVE LEMONY, LEMONY I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WIENER I
WIENER I CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER THREE IS ASSEMBLY AB
1970. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON
MENTAL HEALTH BLACK MENTAL
HEALTH NAVIGATOR CERTIFICATION.
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL
. SENATOR NGUYEN GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER
WIENER. AYE. CURRENT VOTE IS 8
TO 0. WILL HOLD A ROW. OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB 1975 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA MEDI-CAL MEDICALLY
SUPPORTIVE FOOD AND NUTRITION
INTERVENTIONS. CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SEN WHEN
GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
WIENER WIENER I. CURRENT VOTE
EIGHT ZERO. HOLD A ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CURRENT VOTE IS 8 TO
0, CHAIR VOTING AYE, PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL. SENATOR GONZALEZ,
SMALL WOULD CUEVAS WIENER WIENER
A CURRENT VOTE IS NINE ZERO.
WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS, NEXT ITEM, ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN, AB 2786. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA CERTIFIED MOBILE
FARMERS MARKETS. CURRENT VOTE 8
TO 0. CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. WIENER Ã.
WIENER. Ã. CURRENT VOTE 9 TO 0
WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT AB 3161. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, BONTA. HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES, PATIENT SAFETY AND
ANTIDISCRIMINATION AN CURRENT
VOTE EIGHT ZERO CHAIR VOTING
AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR. GONZALEZ. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS WIENER. WIENER A CURRENT
VOTE 9 TO 0 WILL HOLD THE ROLL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. I THINK
YOU ARE TO THANK YOU. PUT UP BY
789756789. OKAY. GONZALEZ. IS
THAT ONE? AND THEN NINE. YOU
WANT TO RECESS? YEAH. SHE'S
PRESENTING. WELL, LET'S LET'S
JUST RECESS FOR TEN. WHAT, FIVE
MINUTES? THERM MEMBERS QUESTIONS
AND, ASSEMBLY EDUCATION. SO
SHE'S ANSWERING QUESTIONS. I
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG THAT WILL
TAKE. WHATEVER YOU CALL HIM,
YOU'D SAY FIVE MINUTES AND THEN
GO OVER. OKAY SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WILL BE IN RECESS FOR
FIVE MINUTES.
FROM OUR BRIEF BREAK, WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLES ON THE
BILLS, STARTING WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE, AB 1316, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ERWIN. EMERGENCY SERVICES,
PSYCHIATRIC EMERGENCY MEDICAL
CONDITIONS. THE VOTE IS NINE
ZERO. CHAIR. VOTING AYE, PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. SENATOR GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. THAT MATTER IS OUT. TEN
ZERO TEN ZERO. ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB 1926. CURRENT VOTE IS SEVEN
ZERO. CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. SENATOR NGUYEN
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS VOTE IS 8 TO
0. THAT MATTER IS OUT. NEXT
ITEM. ITEM NUMBER THREE AB 1970.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON MENTAL
HEALTH BLACK MENTAL HEALTH
NAVIGATOR CERTIFICATION. CURRENT
VOTE IS 8 TO 0. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
SENATOR NGUYEN. GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ. AYE. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS.
VOTE IS NINE ZERO. THAT MATTER
IS OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB 1975 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA MEDI-CAL MEDICALLY
SUPPORTIVE FOOD AND NUTRITION
INTERVENTIONS. CURRENT VOTE
EIGHT ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SENATOR.
WHEN GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. VOTE IS NINE
ZERO. THAT MATTER IS OUT NOW.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CURRENT
VOTE IS NINE ZERO. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS VOTE IS TEN
ZERO. THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB 2786. CURRENT VOTE NINE
ZERO. CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
VOTE IS TEN ZERO. THAT MATTER IS
OUT. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB 3161.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES. PATIENT SAFETY
AND ANTIDISCRIMINATION. CURRENT
VOTE NINE ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS VOTE TEN ZERO. THAT
MATTER IS OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB 2063. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN. HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO
CHAIR VOTING AYE. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE. SENATOR GONZALEZ I,
GONZALEZ I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
VOTE TEN ZERO. THAT MATTER IS
OUT. NEXT ITEM. ITEM NUMBER 11 A
B 2081. ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES.
SUBSTANCE ABUSE RECOVERY AND
TREATMENT PROGRAMS. CURRENT VOTE
NINE ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE. SENATOR
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS VOTE IS TEN ZERO. THAT
MATTER IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER 12 IS
OUT. ITEM NUMBER 13 IS OUT. ITEM
NUMBER 14 IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER 16
AB 2365. ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY.
PUBLIC HEALTH KRATOM. CURRENT
VOTE NINE ZERO CHAIR VOTING AYE.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL. SEN.
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. VOTE TEN ZERO. THAT
MATTER IS OUT. AND THE LAST
ITEM. ITEM NUMBER 21 AB 3221.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE. REVIEW OF RECORDS. CURRENT
VOTE NINE ZERO. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS VOTE TEN ZERO.
THAT MATTER IS OUT. THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS. THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED. YES.